episode i forgot of the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you have watched three or
more of my lives we have beef okay it's
not cool
guys
it's free to subscribe if you don't
subscribe and you're watching this stuff
for free it's just it's not cool okay so
and the reason you guys should subscribe
and turn on your notifications is
because every friday thursday and
saturday i do a live show so
if you guys want to be notified
other things our sponsor today is
cooking with chris so cooking with chris
offers a completely customized meal plan
guys i'm down five or six kgs i don't
know what the conversion is 12 pounds
in like three weeks on this meal plan it
works the link is in the descr in the
description
and it helps support the show and all
super chats will be read
okay now i'm done with my intro
so
i think everyone should go around say
your name your age your relationship
status and where you're from
and where people can find you
so my name is junior i'm 23 i'm
currently single and i'm from belgium
but i grew up in south london
my name is chris i'm also single i'm
from wilson keynes and i'm 28 years old
i am emily
aka ej um and i'm 23. i'm also single
and i grew up in swindon in the west
country
where's swindon
i'm in london no swindon is not in
london when i say it people think i'm
saying sweden and i'm like yeah yeah
let's go with that that's interesting um
no it's it's just east of bristol oh
okay close around there okay
uh my name is kit i'm 28 years old i'm
single and you can find me at k
underscore is underscore me
okay i grew up in london
okay guys so
the topic tonight
is can
you turn a hoe into a housewife
but in order to answer this question i
think we got to define what is a hoe
so i want to hear from the guys
what do you guys think a hoe is
going chris
to me
[Music]
what i would call her is
a girl that's
been run through
that you know about like if you don't
know she if you don't know she hasn't
been running through then like you can't
really you don't know on it but once you
know and it's out there like
she just has that name like you know
that you have a chance
what is what does rant through to you
like is there is it a number or is it
like
yeah but
if you know somebody that smashed or you
know a couple people that smashed okay
okay that's a hell and obviously like a
number if it's
relative to age isn't it but
if we're talking like
near the hundreds
oh hundreds yeah like oh gosh do you
know do you know girls that are near the
hundreds
i do i'm like i don't know anyone that's
slept with that many people
well that's a girl anyway you shouldn't
be near that but if you need this then
so so if you know like one friend that
slept with her she's a hell
it depends on the friend okay there's
some people you're like yo like he
smashed
okay
so like if you don't rate him
yeah if you don't really so if you don't
rate him and he's been there you're like
you have to be a hoarder
like if he's ugly or something or what
what do you mean like if the guy is ugly
or like his value yeah like i think i
mean it's more of a guy thing like we
just know
if you smash them oh okay not like you
first might be saying like in general if
you know that someone like you smash
then
okay you're going
is that is that not more of a
is that not more of a reflection of your
male friends though what what you think
of your male friends as opposed to the
girl if you're kind of saying if you've
smashed him
like
do you know what i mean
is that yeah is that is that norm not
more of a reflection of what you think
of the guy than the girl yeah but
there's also like there's levels in it
like
there's levels too and
you can say reflection of this person
and that person but end of the day and
if you're her
you just know from both sides that you
are
in the fine words of cardi b a hoe never
gets cold
this is my like saying there's like a
whole study that was released about this
recently which was but hoes don't get
caught so like geordie girls up north in
newcastle renowned for going out in kind
of minus degree weather in the shortest
skirts at the highest hills yeah no
coats but somehow they're absolutely
fine don't get cold every southerner
would be like
and so
someone did a whole study about cardi b
in this song saying that hoes never get
cold you know they can always wear like
minimal clothing right and they don't
get cold they're fine they're doing
their thing
um someone did a whole like masters or
phd thesis on it or whatever
yeah so so kit what is your definition
about how
oh do you call women house you kind of
strike me as a guy that wouldn't
i don't call women highs horace
okay you know like people are
promiscuous okay
what jordan peterson would say
um
but by definition of you know the slang
of what we would call a quote unquote i
think if a girl if a girl
has
quote unquote gotten around i think
she's going around like a friendship
group then to that group she's going to
be seen as that she's going to be seen
as that do you know what i mean because
it's one thing to
it's one thing to get around but then
if everybody knows and you're still just
acting that way
then
you don't
if you then you're not fussed about your
reputation in that sense because you
because the reality is you know that
it's gonna play a part
do you know what i mean yeah so
if you know that your reputation
if you don't care about your reputation
then you're just gonna do you which is
fine each to their own
but then people are going to call you
what it is do not mean that's true yeah
yeah i kind of feel like it depends on
the motive
um
behind it so
like they could be subject a and b
one
could have slept with 20 and uh the
second person i slept with 20 as well
but the way the first person must have
done it like she could have just been
gassed up by her friends and said you
know what let me just go on mad one
tonight and just just run through 10
people at once
or bro or the second person
like they they fell for one put like
they weren't too smart in relation so
they liked one guy and then thought he
was gonna treat her nice got [ __ ] over
yeah that's another guy got [ __ ] over
but the thing is her mercy behind it
wasn't to be a whole like to run around
you it didn't just happen sort of thing
so i feel like it depends on the motive
interesting
okay so
for the women
yeah
do you do you think does sexual past
matter to you in a guy the sexual past
so oh like would it
like if a guy had slept with a hundred
girls before he met you do you care
no
couldn't can i swear on this by the way
yeah you can swallow oh great
yeah i don't it's not a thing for me i
don't care especially i think if we're
talking numbers i feel like people
view sexual past
really quantitatively
really in terms of numbers and things i
don't think that's a reflection at all
of what kind of a partner you are
sexually or otherwise
i've slept with people who have slept
with loads of people who are [ __ ] in bed
i've slept with people who've slept with
minimal people and it worked well in bed
we were great whatever we had a good
relationship
so i think in terms of the quality of
the relationship you have with them
whether it's a fleeting relationship or
a lasting one i like
yeah it doesn't matter for me it's more
about how someone treats people yeah
to me there's a number where it's kind
of okay
i was having this conversation if you
slept with anyone in my family cooked
any of my sisters
yeah i mean
i feel like that's weird close close
friends cooked
close like immediate front cooked
so just anyone that you know no but i
don't here's the thing i don't have that
many friends
there's like three people you cannot
sleep
[Laughter]
um but i don't know like i guess if it's
extreme like if i did i you can't say
you say corn instead of okay
but if i got a corn cooked like that's
like to the extreme but for the most
part like i don't really care
but it's interesting so i'm gonna ask
the guys the same question
sexual past with a girl does it matter
to you
yeah you start
so sexual past in sense of if we're in
london
and
all right because we're in eastern i use
islam and there's eight guys i know in
east london i've been with
it's game over like
yeah so that sort of passed but if if i
never knew what it did in the past and
you just came and no one knows you i
could really care less
okay when i was yeah yeah you want to
feel like you you found her yeah you
don't want to
have a girl that you know everyone has
had because like the value of it goes
away like you don't want to treat her
the same because you know like yeah
and she
she like she gave her up easy for the
next man then it's like well you're
dickheaded in there like you're spending
this amount of money this amount of time
yeah and you could have done less and
got the same thing yeah so
yeah
and that's the interesting thing like i
think guys care a lot more about that
than girls
um
like i don't think girls really care at
all for the most part
but i wonder if if part of that is
because you know you're saying about
i want to feel like i found her i want
to feel like
ah
i just
i wonder if part of that is is
is to do with how we
view women within relationships and that
you
you want to feel like someone's yours or
like they've not if they've not been
with other people you feel like oh that
i think so sometimes as well i think it
can be a thing of
i think guys feel threatened by it
sometimes of like you've slept with
multiple other people you could sleep
with more people after me yeah it's like
but in a relationship i choose you
but the thing is like men are
biologically predispositioned to be like
different than us so like we have
biological roots and like historically
men had to ensure paternity
so like when girls had more partners
that would make it harder for them to
ensure that that's their kid
and so that's like why biologically like
they're different than women because for
us like if if he'd slept with someone
else like that's a sign of pre-selection
which like like if a girl do you guys
know anyone with a check mark
yeah like a blue check mark yeah do they
get hoes
yeah like he doesn't indulge but yeah he
you get his girls
yeah but he's a very good looking guy as
well but yeah but like he's checked but
that's like another sign of social
status yeah of course so it's like
different for men and women do you think
does that like bother you
as a girl like do you care about that i
don't know well if
that like because a lot of girls get mad
when i talk to them like that men like
look at it one way and like women look
at another
um i mean i think it i think i think
i think it also depends what who who
you're surrounded by
i think if you're in social circles
where you all
are of the same belief that it doesn't
really matter across the board
um
then that's one thing i think
i think people are entitled to their
opinions okay i would never say to
someone you have to think and act
exactly like me right right
but i would raise the point that i feel
like sometimes people form opinions
based on prejudice okay or based on past
experiences i think that shapes
everyone's belief systems what do you
what do you mean by prejudice
so i think for some people so i'm i'm i
i'm i'm going to put this one out here
okay
okay i'm an arden feminist i believe in
equality
and i believe in total equality and
that's not me saying that's not me
saying i think that there are no
biological differences between men and
women i'm not an idiot
i completely agree with that especially
we and we talked about this
there there are strong physical
differences right between men and women
men in general stronger do you so then
do you pay for the dates like do you 50
50 on dates yeah oh always for the most
part if someone look i think it's a
really nice thing if someone offers to
pay for you on a date
but i think that regardless i'm also bi
i like women and men okay so i think
that regardless of whether
um
i think that regardless of gender i
think it's a really nice thing to in the
same way like if someone holds the door
for me like thank you that is a nice
thing to do it's a nice thing to offer
to pay for someone
but
especially within the sphere of of
yeah of dating i think
i think i think i think why not i think
if someone offers and you're like no no
let's split and they're like no i
insist okay fine i don't know i've just
found that like a lot of girls i talk to
like they want equality but it's like
only when it benefits them
so like they want like because i don't
think body count is really that big of a
deal like in the term like if that's the
only double standard that like is
negative towards us like i don't think
that's that bad
but i i would say that's absolutely not
the the only doubles within within the
whole world that's definitely not the
only double standard i think it's a big
one that we can point out because i
think historically women are always
slut-shamed yeah i think even the thing
of calling someone a hoe or a [ __ ] like
especially [ __ ] that's such a harsh
word
um and i think it's conflating someone
who has multiple sexual partners with
someone who sells their body for a
living
but equally and i'm sure we're going to
talk about this afterwards yeah i
equally i'm like cool great on your coin
yeah again like i don't care if you want
to be someone who does sell sex or is a
sex worker i'm like okay but i think in
general like i think
i i think the body count isn't isn't the
only thing but it's a big one that we
can point to and i think that i
understand your reasoning
about biologically you know men men can
father way more children than women can
right right mother kids
but
we're way past that point now we are way
past the point of just
intellectually
and i think that it's just interesting
because if body count didn't actually
matter like why wouldn't everyone just
say theirs
you know what i mean like usually like
people lie one way or the other do you
think well men and men inflate i think
men inflate it like women say it's a lot
lower yeah and like usually like if i
ask people and so like would you want to
tell your body count on live
i i would love to
i can give you an estimate wait really
give you an estimate if i don't if you
want no that's not because you don't
know the exact number or you just
guess
estimate because i
yeah because i i don't know i don't know
because i don't keep a checklist of
everyone that i've slept with because i
think that would be a little bit yeah
strange like oh so you wouldn't care
like you would say it on the live and
like you wouldn't even care yeah like it
because i think as well i think it's
important to break down social stigma
for things like that okay in the same
way i think if if guys you know if guys
feel a pressure to big up the number of
people they've slept with because they
feel like that makes them cooler and
women feel like they need to tell a
lower number because that makes them
seem more attractive you don't think
shame exists for a reason because i feel
like shame is something internal like no
one can make you feel shame
oh i think people can make you feel
shaped i don't think so oh i think i
think we internalize it but i think it's
stuff that we learn like i use the
example of i used to pray the gay away
when i was a kid cause i was raised race
catholic
bad catholic now
did you do did you have um uniforms in
school
no i didn't i didn't go to oh yeah yeah
did i have uniforms yeah i didn't go to
a catholic school yeah but but
normal schools have yeah yeah that's why
i i i have a question do you think
do you think that calling a girl like a
hoe
is the same thing as calling a guy broke
[Music]
because like
because corner girl a hoe is like
supposed to see you're saying that to
make her less desirable to guys right
yeah yeah so calling the guy broke
is just saying he's not desirable to
women because women don't want guys who
are broke you're surprised
but at the same time you know
realistically like someone could be a
[ __ ] and it could have really mattered
to you you still do well yeah and a guy
can be broke and it may not matter yeah
like is it the same thing no no but it's
different though because like
if if he was ashamed to be broke
especially like in public a girl
wouldn't be like hmm
this they still wouldn't feel the same
way if they did if that makes sense if
they knew he was broke do you think so
maybe behind closed doors so if it was
like oh they just met the guy they don't
know it was broke
they could already care less then yeah
but then
if in public you just got cussed out and
you're like yeah you're broke all the
girls would like
yeah i'm saying yeah that like he would
he would look less desirable to them
yeah but then if it was the other way
around where they were calling a girl a
hoe like oh yo
guys would be like yeah and i said no
but the thing is
what i'll say is that if guys believe
that
they may still have sex with her but
they wouldn't wife her up though yeah
you're saying that that do you see my
point i got a question what you're
saying so
um if a guy if a guy is broke yeah
he can become unbroken by getting money
yep so you can let for example win the
lottery get a good job you know just he
can he can turn that around yes you can
but how can a woman turn around being a
hoe because that got moved cities boy
it's got me
[Music]
yeah they stopped they got guys around
the area like say they're from south
they they they are guys from like north
or east or west because they're too big
in the area and it works for them
i think
but then is is i would argue that it's
not a mentality like i would say as a
poster you can never you want you know
that argument of once you're broke and
and i would like to also say that i i
think that this
i think it's a bit of an americanism
anyway this thing like he broke or
whatever like whatever you're going to
call it i think like in england at least
i think i think some of that bleeds in
from popular culture right there's that
song by tlc no scrubs right
but i think for me i'm like it's a tune
right
[Music]
well i think
but i think like i think i think
again in the same way that you can you
can earn money
um and i would yeah i'd like to say that
someone having no money has never
stopped me from dating them i'm working
class i wasn't raised with a right
silver spoon in my mouth but i would say
in the same way that this kind of if
we're talking about poems like i've had
whole phases or whatever
i think it's more i think i think it's
less about how many people you've slept
with and maybe your mentality the people
that you're sleeping with so i would say
if you view being a hoe
exclusively in terms of numbers then
sure like i can't magically unsleep with
people yeah i hear that but what do you
guys think like as as guys like do you
think it's more of a mentality or is it
just like a number
like when you're vetting a girl to like
date her i think i i think it's a
mentality because thing is it's like
the reason the reason i don't
think it's a number is because i would
rather like a girl has slept with 20
guys that i don't know than two of my
friends oh yeah we talked about those do
you know what i mean yeah so because i
think especially for guys
and it varies from guy to guy but i
think especially if he's taking a girl
seriously like no guy wants to have
another man at his wedding who's been
inside his wife
they don't
so like part of it is like part of it is
part of it is like a respect thing among
your peers for men so equally
you know a lot of women
and i hear what you're saying about the
americanism right but i think the
difference is
in american culture they're just a lot
more direct whereas in british culture
here we're very
that the underlying thing is the
intention is still there
but we just don't openly say it so like
for example
you know if one of your girlfriends
meets a new guy the first thing they ask
is what does he do
yeah yeah that's very true what does
that have anything to do with other than
how well can he provide
it's exact same thing otherwise you know
it's like if you didn't do anything or
they want to see like show me a picture
what's the other thing huh the girls
will either say what does he do or let
me see
a picture yeah whereas guys
your boy just met your girl they're like
yo what's she look like
um so i think i think it i think it is
mindset because
a girl can
have 20 guys but i think it's like no
one knows that no one knows but i also
think you're a production of your habits
and i think that's like
you can't
undo like the habits you've created the
past like like
you can change your habits i think you
can but i think it's hard it could be
hard but and i don't think most people
do
i think most girls that i know that like
slept around have a hard time
not doing it anymore
no i i disagree because i think a lot of
them i think a lot of them get
a lot of them get burned
um
actually the numbers the numbers don't
support you actually what would it be
because they surveyed women that had
like slept with more people right yeah
and they surveyed them and how much they
regretted sleeping with those like the
person right and the lower the number
was the more they regretted it but also
the more likely they were like the more
people they slept with the more likely
they were to do it again and the more
regret they felt they still would do it
again
so basically we're saying is the more
people that she slept with the more
likely she is to sleep with more people
like yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's like
we call it hoe tendencies
but i also
would say that part of that is because i
think women who
date more frequently will have more
frequent partners or have slept with
more people
are less willing to settle
yeah i think that's another thing but
what do you define as settling because
i don't i don't just mean settling down
as in finding going steady with someone
okay and getting married because i think
i totally respect that i'm like if that
works for you some people really really
love
to have the comfort of a really of a
long-term relationship who doesn't it
offers you security emotionally if
you're married financially right think
of those sweet tax breaks
right but i mean in terms of some people
i think they
are so desperate
to
be in a relationship
and and
and so they they settle down or they get
into a relationship with someone who
they already know isn't right for them
or someone where they go yeah you know
he he treats me to a base level of okay
so i go all right yeah you know he he
gives me attention he gives me love i'll
go for him how is it how is it
because i always wonder because people
always say like settling but isn't like
settling what you can get
it's not really settling if that's the
best you can get and i think every girl
is gonna take the best guy that she can
get to commit to her
but i think just like guys i think are
gonna get the hottest nice like hottest
slash you know wifey quality girl that
they can get to yeah but i think part of
the problem is or maybe problem is the
wrong word i think part of the thing is
that people settle down too early
before they've actually found that
person who is the best they can get they
find someone who's best in that very
moment but not the person they don't go
okay who's someone who's going to be
good for me
for a long time and i think that's when
people get trapped in relationships
which then they can't grow in and they
become toxic or they're not fun
so i would rather have more partners and
find someone where i go okay i so so in
my kind of dating life it tends to be
that i'll date someone for a few months
and i have a period of dating them more
casually and then you kind of pass
through levels right um in terms of you
know do you pass these things okay we we
we go up we don't just start like okay
you've met my parents after the first
date right um
and it's so if you pass these things and
i go okay more and more i'm thinking
we're people who are more and more
compatible and i think that takes time
to work that out mm-hmm so and i think
if it gets to a point where you go
actually i don't think we are i don't
then go
okay well i'm gonna stick with it anyway
because i've given you six months i go
okay actually no fine yeah but the the
issue with that is like the more women
or the more men that a woman has slept
with like her chance of a happy marriage
goes down like drastically so if a
girl's a virgin she has an 80 chance of
having a happy marriage
and it goes down to like 20 30 if she's
slept with more than five people
really yeah
and it's like the sa it's like
marital happiness it's like um
satisfaction with her partner because
like think about it the more people
you've experienced the more you have it
to compare to it it's the same thing men
it's similar like if a man's a virgin
like that's the highest like happiness
rate in marriage for him too but like
men it doesn't drop like i think a guy
that slept with like three girls is less
happy than a guy that's slept with eight
i don't know like it's not as drastic
like it is for women
and i also feel like it's a sort of
thing to do with sensitivity so like
your first date wouldn't be the same as
like your 30th date because like the
first day it felt a bit more special but
i keep dating more people and getting
around more people you become less
sensitive to like
like
um the things that come with dating and
stuff so it will just look like a normal
thing anymore so you won't
it will be harder for you to just settle
and be like all right cool
i think i found a person could be like i
think i can actually do better than this
and they just keep on
i think it's like and i'm just going
from um
like women that i've coached and one or
two female friends i think a very common
thing with some women is that what will
happen is
they'll date a guy he'll have one great
quality so imagine he is like super
intelligent right and then things don't
work out she's like okay
well now i want to find a guy who's
super intelligent
and then tall she then finds that guy is
that okay he's intelligent he's tall
but now i want to find let's say that
doesn't work out right then she comes
across the next guy okay let's say he's
intelligent
he's got good finances but he's not tall
then he's okay i want to find a guy
who's intelligent good finances tour and
it's like
you almost the great things from the
previous partner you want that in an
addition to the next partner and that's
like a trap because then what ends up
happening is you you have this long list
that ends up trying to be the perfect
person you're looking for and that just
doesn't exist and i think with guys like
it definitely happens with guys i think
from like a sexual standpoint but i
don't i don't think that's a bad thing i
don't think that's a bad thing to go i
had this relationship and i grew from it
and i went actually i don't want that in
the next relationship i go actually i
see that behavioral pattern and i can
identify and go i don't want that in the
next relationship think i don't think
that's a bad thing at all well i think
it's it's more supply and demand
and i think it's just like
because basically if you look at dating
app data
it's like
80 of women are swiping on less than 20
percent of the guys
so this like not settling like leaves us
as like so like rotation type girl like
because you're with
you're going after a guy that is effing
with multiple girls
he's like most guys if they're given the
option are gonna share the same under
yeah yeah they're sharing the same guy
yeah and so it's like then
the more the more and more we like don't
settle the like the more and more a
smaller percentage of men are sleeping
with all the girls and like i don't
think that leads to like long-term
happiness
being a side [ __ ] like is but is that
not also also the case in natural
selection anyway like if we talk about
how
men are able to father more children
that happens in the natural environment
i would say for sure like
dating apps are a cesspit right right
they're not exactly the most natural
environment but i would say that happens
naturally anyway and i think that
happens even if if you if you have a
group of guys together okay you can
easily point out for the most part like
objective attractiveness of course i'm
that's not accounting for that love is
blind and sometimes people go for people
and you're like really i'm not attracted
to them at all people like different
rights
like if you find them attractive someone
else does too like yeah yeah i got you
yeah yeah so it's i i think that's i
think that's a normal thing that
for sure like we were talking about
abundance before the top the most
attractive guys getting the most girls
that happens in real life and on dating
apps i think maybe it's amplified more
because it is so kind of yes or no yes
or no and it takes out the whole getting
to know someone thing like but yeah i
would say if well i think i think it
happens like naturally but
i just think it's getting to the point
where it's like a little bit extreme
because you hear girls will say like six
inches six figures
what is it six inches six figures
six pack yeah
and like how many
and like
and even like even me right so i'm i'm
tall right so i'm six foot and if if
girls want a guy that's above six foot
that's 15
of men so that's a very like again it's
a small percentage then you add in
money you add in like other layers
but we had we had this conversation
didn't we because i was like the amount
of girls i know who on a surface level
are kind of kind of say six foot and
over and then as soon as they're offered
dating up and they meet someone in a bar
and they're like five foot seven no he's
the love of my life that's true that's
true that's true on people on paper as
well they they say they want these
things and right actually they meet that
person and it's like we we see that in
shows where they match people on on
paper and then they bring them on a date
together and sometimes they have no
chemistry i think it doesn't account for
the fact that so much of attraction we
actually can't pin down something is
sometimes it's just so it's something
that you can't um
like it's just it's just a random
something and you can't pin it down to
whether it's height or whatever i think
of course people have
base levels of and again the same thing
of natural selection i think it's just i
think it's just more like societal
trends right that we're seeing so like
for example like women aren't settling
because the average age of first
marriage keeps going up and up and up
like you know what it is in the uk
no i don't it's 31 and 32. in ireland i
was just there it's 34 and 35. is it
that high now and they're predicting
that 50 percent of women will be single
and childless like 20 i think 50 of
women over 30 yeah we'll be single and
childless so it's all single children
so so it's like like the these patterns
aren't conducive for families because
it's not good for kids to not have both
parents in the home
yeah like that's you know what i'm
saying like it's not conducive to
building family this is just like the
trends we're seeing you know what i mean
can i ask you a question yeah which
would you rather
see
a guy who you're really really into once
every two weeks
or a guy you're only kind of into
twice a week
the first one the first one the first
one as well because my dating style is
very much i'm quite independent and i
work i work in film i work quite a
demanding job sometimes i can be on set
for 12 hours yeah i or longer i've
worked in a job before i was on for 16
hours yeah sweet sweet over time
but um so it's mainly because you're
busy right a busy and also just in
general my both of my parents are quite
independent people
my mom loves to sit at home and read
she's she's she's very
she's she's so neutral she's so she's so
calm my mom has such a calming presence
in my life and my dad is like me and my
dad is bat [ __ ] and i love it but my
parents they work so well together
because no one could date my dad like my
mom and no one could date my mom like my
dad and they balance each other out
really well and they are both very
independent people and they're very
happy to do their own thing they don't
need to be in each other's space all the
time and i really like that and that's
something i like now and the thing that
i admire and i tend to date people who
are busy bodies and people who are
ambitious and things because that's the
quality i have and i also like people
who who uh who want to do other things
and i'm not their self hobby
cool with a boyfriend you see twice a
month sure
the reason the reason i asked that
question is because i think
it's exactly that reason
that
the date in landscape is the way it is
now because most girls would rather see
the guy they really want
less
than the guy who's ready to be there for
them more
i think which end which is how you end
up having one guy
having six seven eight nine girls
because they would oral i don't know why
you're laughing
is this what's happening to you at the
moment absolutely
no but it's true but it's true though
like they'd rather see they'd rather
like they draw this [ __ ] you know do you
know man they have it i know
you know
a couple yeah
but but i would i would say who wants to
see someone that they kind of like of
course everybody wants to see the
blessing
what i'm trying to say is like there i
think before they used to prioritize
commitment
a bit not over quality but
more compared to quality but now it's
like we only care about quality and if
it means i only get five percent of him
then i'd rather take that but i don't
think the amount of time you spend with
someone equates commitment look at
long-term relationships you can still be
in a really committed relationship if
it's a long uh if it's long distance
sorry not long-term if it's a
long-distance relationship you don't
think there's a higher level of
commitment if you're like living with
someone oh yeah like i mean but i think
it depends on what framework if you've
got bills if you've got shared bills of
course that is right like that's that is
a commitment because you you both
financially have to supply it's like if
one of you loses a job it's like
great
but i think i i i think that people want
different things i know a lot of women
and i know a lot of men who are much
more dependent people and they want to
be with their partner a lot and that's
fine those people tend to find each
other
i think it just depends what kind of
person you are and i think a lot of it
depends how you're raised as well like
if you're raised with parents who love
to be with each other all the time then
i think you learn by that behaviour and
you go this is what a healthy
relationship looks like
and to me i think not being in each
other's space all the time is what i
prefer but for me i'm like okay if you
love being around each other that's
great i still love being around my
partners don't get me wrong it's just
that if i'm working a really long job if
i've got loads of other stuff and i've
got a lot of friends and i want to see
those guys too and i think that's okay i
think if you see someone if you're
living with them like of course i'm
going to see my partner more but i've
never
you know i've not lived with any of my
partners so i'm not having that natural
kind of being around them when i come
home thing in which case i would see
them more
so so coming off his question right say
if you're seeing a guy like every two
weeks
at a certain point like obviously you
guys are sleeping together like every
two weeks what not after say like five
months
i feel like it's safe to say at some
point you'd want to see more
uh
if you are progressing in terms of oh
okay now we're going to buy a house
together or we're going to move in
together then oh no no no no if you want
to take them seriously just yeah like a
serious relationship because i i feel
like
when i got a job sleeping together at
some point
the girl's going to be like cool like
two weeks is a bit of a long time like i
i'd like to know that a lot so once you
narrow it a lot and you're telling me
like look i'm trying to see more often
and he's like
i kind of like it the way it is
i think i think it depends i think it
depends what as well what his reasons is
if it's like sorry i can only see you
two weeks because i'm away for work or
i'm doing this or whatever you go okay
fair enough and also again this is we're
talking within a heteronormative and
monogamous relationship we're not
accounting for anything like polyamory
but if you of you if you're dating
someone monogamously
yeah sometimes people have careers
let me ask the guys um
you guys had had a girlfriend
yeah ever ever yeah ever would they have
been cool with seeing you twice a month
no chance
no chance no i actually um one of my
relationships my longest term
relationship ended because
of long distance and just not seeing
each other as frequently
um
yeah distance is the worst i don't think
long distance relationships work oh my
god yeah i tried that it crashed and
burned
i've tried that too i don't think it
well i think unless you have plans in
place to make it not long distance i
don't think it's sustainable what do you
consider distance like an hour two hours
three i'd say
enough distance where if you couldn't
if they had a really bad day and you
couldn't see them that evening
because they're too far it's too far
it's gonna be like two hours
i'd say five to be honest
you don't think that's what you do you
meet someone to have a bad day for like
four hours
well if they were like five hours away
if they're four hours away
my long distance she was in australia
like oh yeah oh oh so anything closer
than that
i could probably do america uk
really because you got the time
difference i mean same with you as well
you've got a time difference yeah
there's only so many hours like a window
where you can really like chat to each
other yeah yeah yeah yeah so
if you missed that
okay i'm gonna read super chats really
quick um thank you guys for the super
chats just so you guys know
all super chats um
i i i don't even pay myself at this
point it's just being reinvested into
the studio we're doing a studio revamp
in the next week it's gonna be really
cool we're getting more mics we're
getting more equipment
thankful for all of you guys because you
guys are the ones that really make this
happen also like the video there's 105
of you in here
like that's dope okay
um let's start with the super chats um
five dollars from blue pill unplugged um
a 304 is a bad bet for paternity a guy
can't be sure who his kid is hard line
in the sand next one 899 from samuel udo
saying you'd rather sleep around and
have more soul ties as well to me
um
i am just jewels five dollars love
seeing the improvements keep it up okay
thank you guys
um
also guys if you send any more i'll read
them like pretty quick
so next question
would you date a girl with an only fan
seriously and guys for us i'm gonna i'm
gonna answer first no i wouldn't why
wouldn't you why yeah
because um i don't want the father of my
like if i i would think of it as like a
long-term thing right i wouldn't want a
guy that i like i'm with publicly and
like father like that i'm a i feel like
it's like a brand like you know what i
mean because when you get married or
date someone that's they're like part of
your brand and i just feel like that's
not representing me
well because that's not something like i
would do or stand for so would you you
wouldn't you wouldn't
if you did own your fans but then when
you got serious he stopped that wouldn't
be okay
no you can't ever have done it
okay i just feel like if i could date
someone who had not done it like why
would i not there's so many men out
there
like i think i could find one
guys follow my only fans
does it matter if the coin is really
good
you've changed your life
he can't change my life
[Music]
like respectfully um
no he can't like
no i i just think like because like then
what kind of person are you
you're like you change your values for
money
to an extent yeah yeah
that's honest out here man lisa's honest
right
i thought about this and i've been
through certain things i'm just like
i know money isn't everything yet but
at this point in my life
i collect
i'll collect yeah yeah i know i mean i
under i understand like not everyone was
raised and like i had a really good
situation growing up so i understand but
like
i just i feel like a long-term
relationship is kind of like a brand
and i feel like that's not what like i
would want my family
being known for is like the girl who's
dating someone with only fans
and even if it was like the best guy
ever like he he
he brought everything other than monday
night he was quite caring uh-huh he
looks for your needs he was actually
like for you but i wouldn't i wouldn't
want to get to that point
no but you never knew this you never
opened up because no one normally lied
oh no i'm in love you want to say it no
you're already pregnant with this child
well if you already knocked me off then
i'm of course like
it's your 20th no no because it's like
no i mean if i if i was pregnant i would
stay but that'd be very dishonest to not
emily would you would you date a guy who
doesn't know any friends i'm about to
shock you all and uh and say i couldn't
give a [ __ ] um
i'm not i actually thought you were
gonna say that
did you you didn't think i was gonna no
i thought you were gonna say that yeah
yeah the the shocking bit that was that
was sarcasm yeah
yeah no i mean um i i have friends i
have friends who do only fans i view
them the exact same way as i did before
they had it uh i know so i don't know
any guys who do only fans i have a
friend who approached me because he
wanted to start an only fans with you
no no not with me although he did he did
ask if he could use my film expertise to
help him set it up
which i thought was jokes um
no it it man was trying it you know
no he didn't end up doing it because he
worked like he works a corporate job
right he was just kind of going i kind
of want a little bit of money on the
side he's a bit of a hire like if fine
like but
it doesn't it doesn't bother me again
because i think
i can separate someone and their
career and i think if that's what you
want to do if that's how you earn your
money i think if you enjoy it you're not
being exploited in the sense of you know
you've not got a pimp there saying you
have to do this or i'm going to beat you
up if you if you know if this is how you
make your money i think ultimately if
you're someone who goes
i'm doing this at the moment because
and i actually hate it and i wish i was
doing something else i think that's sad
but i think there's a lot of people who
go actually i like the money and i'm
happy to do this because i'd rather do
this than sell myself for a corporate
job or sell my body breaking it stacking
shelves intestines because i think
whatever i agree with you like i don't
care like i don't care what people do
like it's not my business like what you
do in your personal time and i don't
think that says who you are as a person
but i just think like
you should be selective in who you date
but i guess for me that's not really
something that would determine whether
or not i'd be interested
in other ways right right yeah yeah
don't clarify with the only fans because
there's some people who just post like
naked pictures that just become a thirst
trap then it's obvious that just blow it
back out why don't you say where it
would matter to you
where would it matter to you
oh you
no no only first period but i'll just
for you like you wouldn't mind your your
man like blowing backs out on your pants
i could yeah i literally couldn't care
less i couldn't care less if you were
having gay bear back with like an orgy
it really like it it doesn't bother me
but you were
jesus jesus has left the chat but
what did you be nervous about like if
you had kids and i'm like making fun of
like
i mean who in in in your day-to-day life
so i follow a couple on instagram
they're called the london vagabond
they're a kink couple okay they
photograph kink
and people ask this question of of them
as well about whether or not um you know
what do their kids think of it what are
they
your normal parents don't talk about
your sex life
you're so it's it's some it's a similar
thing if you have a kink a particular
kink again of course you're not going to
it's an age-appropriate thing i'm not
going to talk to my kids about the sex
that i have right generally speaking in
in a kind of yeah me and your dad yeah
but i think like even even like friends
that i know that have had like ho ho
moms
at some point they find out
like the kids grow up and they find out
right that's your role model though
and i guess maybe if you don't see
anything like wrong with that then like
we probably would just have different
like world views right because yeah i
would see something wrong with that you
probably wouldn't right but i also think
i think it's dependent on
i in general even if i've slept with a
lot of people even if someone has slept
with a lot of people that doesn't mean
that they're sleeping with people who
aren't good people they might just be
finding lots of good people in the same
way i think if you have a kid i think
that's a different game i think because
you are then way more selective because
you're bringing someone in
right is then coming into contact with
your kid especially i mean i think it's
different if you're going as a parent
i'm sleeping with them they're never
coming into contact with my kid but if
if your child has seen you bring people
back i think again that that child you
have to think about that child then who
is around your child so i think that's a
different point right um i guess when i
date like i look more like long-term you
know what i mean so that's like the way
i think is like it would be more of a
long-term like prospect you know what i
mean yeah but i think in general i don't
sleep with people that i don't respect
right i would never sleep with someone
that i didn't respect someone that i
didn't like and i think part of the
problem of people not being able to have
long-term relationships is that they
don't date people thinking can i be
friends with this person do i actually
like this person do i just want to i
don't think guys do that i think
i think more girls do that what and
i think even if a girl is looking at a
guy casually like she'll still care if
he's a decent person yeah whereas i
think yeah for sure a lot of guys can
separate that completely but well also
but i also think because mainly like
most guys don't have that level of
abundance so they'll take what they can
get
you think you don't you don't think most
guys have no i i agree i just feel like
you can
for example you can have a girl that
you're like that's your girl
and you can just
you can be with anybody like it doesn't
matter with enough that's the point that
i'm making like yeah i agree with you
okay yeah
like yeah like it don't matter it could
be it doesn't work
she can be old young
victims like any it don't matter like
it's just for that moment yeah cause i
think when a guy sees a girl that he
finds attractive without even knowing
her name if she was like
you're gonna come to this cupboard right
now nine times out of ten he's gonna say
he'd be like yeah but when a girl sees a
guy that's attractive even if she's like
oh he's really hot
a lot of the time and correct me if i'm
wrong ladies but i feel like a lot of
time you'd still be like even though i
would have said you i kind of still want
to know if you're a decent person before
i do it's more like i don't want to
catch anything
like i'm not trying to run a bad std and
you can't have kids so i'm not trying to
yeah please please have please please
have protected sex yeah but you can see
there's still [ __ ] you can catch with
protected sex yeah for sure but but me
and i just feel like if a guy was coming
up to me and asking that i'm like how
many i can't be the first
i mean i mean let's let's put this into
context of real life kit how many times
have women come up to you and gone do
you want to come with me into this back
alley anyone has that ever happened to
any of you guys how's it going not bad
earlier but really openly you've never
had a conversation and they've
propositioned you straight off the bat
has that ever happened to any of you
guys not like the first thing she said
but within like a couple of minutes only
once yeah
the one i've got was
um they would say but very s in such a
way so i remember one time girl was like
oh do you want to come back for cuddles
[Music]
that's that's the line of it
yeah so yeah it'll be very soft it won't
be like guys what are like so what are
you telling me
yeah yeah i think guys the way guys
approach a guy in that manner is
different to how a woman approaches a
guy in a manner
if a girl approaches a guy in the same
way sometimes he can put you off but
you're like
that was a bit too easy right okay
there was nothing for me to work with
like it was just
take it um yeah
see i asked that because from a female
perspective my concern is more the
safety of the fact i don't know who you
are
and it's less about that's true it's
less about the fact you've propositioned
me openly for sex and more about the
fact you could hurt me physically yeah
yeah i don't i don't know you
and also i think it's another thing of
intimacy right so much of sex for me is
intimacy i
couldn't sleep with someone i'd never
even had a conversation with who i knew
i didn't click with because how can i be
vulnerable with this person
first of all like the best sex i've ever
had has been with someone i've either
been in love with or i've been able at
least to be intimate with but you know i
already know them we already know we've
probably already had i'm a very open
person in case you can tell um so i'm
able to have a conversation with the
person i'm about to sleep with or i am
sleeping with about what i like what i
enjoy and if someone propositions you
straight off the bat yeah yeah okay
like the chances of it being good are
quite slim because they don't know who
you are they don't know what you like
they don't know what you enjoy you've
not had any conversation about consent
so i think that's also i think that's
another thing guys what about you with
only fans would you date a girl with
only fans
not seriously no not seriously no no
no i wouldn't sound even though even
though you could understand getting on
it
any guy that would consider himself like
a proper man that would
wife
yeah that old wife
um
a girl that's unonly fans like that
i see i feel like you have something to
see here give her the mic
give the girl the mic
she got some heat
that's strong words um
no just more this thing about uh what
what's what is a proper man well someone
who doesn't
uh yeah i guess to do with saying i'd
say a man with standards
and i think it's like important to like
have standards and we always tell men
where they can't have standards
i think it's important to have standards
but i think that's i don't think again
someone's numbers is a reflection of
their standards or what someone does for
a job but there's there's research that
shows that more of the more partners
like the woman has the less likely she
will be happy in the marriage
and the like the there's higher rates of
depression like there's a lot of things
that that are negative that are linked
to the more people you sleep with so
so so we so can like how is it
bad for a guy to say i don't want to
deal with that because that's just a
standard he has okay the thing i would
challenge with that how big are these
studies and also you cannot isolate
these all of these people have not had
the same life experiences so you cannot
isolate just the amount of people
they've slept with the the control
variables are slim but don't
i agree with you like that's that's
where their discernment comes in but
like i don't think there's anything
wrong with a guy saying like
like that he wouldn't date someone
that's not only fans oh i i um yeah we
we've had this conversation as well i
said again i completely i can't make you
sleep with anybody i can't make you go
yeah absolutely what if you had a son or
a brother like you you really would
encourage them to like date someone with
an only fans it's not even a thing of
encouragement i'm neutral i would
encourage you to not be prejudiced i
would encourage you to view someone for
who they are as a person and i think
what you do for a job and who you've
slept with it's completely irrelevant i
think it's about him so what if he's a
criminal the guy so if a guy if a guy's
a
a criminal and he has a past of like
well it's robbing yeah sex offenses like
you don't think your actions show who
you are oh and what kind of yeah but
again that's not to do with the fact
that he slept with women that's to do
with the way again like that's i think
that's a complete that's well that's so
left but i think but i think no but it
it does because a girl that's slept with
more
men like i think the the issue is
ensuring paternity they're worried that
when in the relationship she's going to
do the same thing because that's her
habits the last couple years the same
way that like if a girl is looking at a
guy and he's cheated in every single
relationship he's been in like that
that's your habit that's what you do
that's who you are as a person okay but
i think sleeping with lots of people
doesn't equate you being a cheater i
think so when you say about a guy can't
guarantee paternity okay but if she's
someone who slept with a lot of people
but monogamously
then the trend is she slept with a lot
of people monogamously so it's like okay
she's only sleeping with you
monogamously we're talking about only
fans oh so so that's what we're talking
about like he said he like his he said
that he like a proper
like man wouldn't date a girl with an
online sh
shall i tell you what i think it is
correct me i'm wrong right is that i
think
the thing that i think sometimes girls
don't understand
about men
is that respect is very important
and respect amongst other men
especially men that you consider your
peers who you value men you look up to
men who look up to you is very important
and
if you're a guy and you have
committed and invested yourself
in
because things there are plenty of women
who may have great qualities as the girl
who hasn't only fans but they don't have
an only fans does that make sense so i
think if you as a man have choose have
chosen to commit and invest yourself in
a woman that you feel doesn't
give great respect to you because your
partner is a reflection of you who you
choose is a reflection of you
then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who i
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so it i think you know
like chris you said you've got a name
right yeah right and you're nigerian in
it yeah so i'm nigerian so respect in
our culture is huge
massive and there are a lot of other
cultures like asian cultures
like there are a lot of other cultures
where respect is very important so
yeah i think um
i think that's when you say about being
a man part of being a man
is having the level of respect that you
desire which is you know a lot of guys
may look at will smith and be like
he doesn't have a lot of respect right
now
do you know what i mean and he hasn't
for a long time i think i think that's a
collective thing i think everybody wants
to be respected and i completely and
again another conversation that we've
had
like societies that are much more
collective they're way less
individualistic
uk especially american society very
individualistic whereas if you're taking
countries asia africa there is a lot
more uh uh importance on what society is
a whole and how you fit into society as
a whole yeah the community and i think
that's a really good thing in some
senses but those countries also have
some of the highest rates of suicide
because they have so much social shame
sorry i'm i think i
just have the highest rates of suicide i
didn't understand third world countries
yeah but
i would say actually have the lowest
rates which is confused a lot of social
scientists yeah they have less look at
like japan it has one of the highest
rates because of social stigma and shame
if they do something wrong
when i went to japan like my my
understanding was it was more like
one um
it's a very individualistic society like
so yeah like people are dying alone in
their apartment there
oh yeah and like and and men are working
themselves to death so i don't i don't
think it's like social stigma but i
don't i'm not saying in terms of
people i'm not talking about people's
isolation because japan also has a
problem with not enough people having
children yeah i know because it's back
to like the individualistic like like
japan has a problem with like women like
that like getting old and not being able
to find husbands basically right now but
historically and it's still the case
that they have very clear social rules
like even in terms of things if you
would never hold hands with your partner
or keep your partner on the street
because
society that's like that's frowned upon
socially really because i went there
when i was younger and like that the
couple i stayed with like they were i
don't know that was not the case for
whatever it's the same
it's like that in uae they're very
strict about like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so and i'm saying more that the thing
with with
with with guys and this thing of okay i
want to be respected by my men and i
completely see that and i completely see
that and and especially in other
countries where that is even more
important or different cultures where
that's really important and what being a
man is differently defined i think
that's why it's important to shift the
societal narrative of what we define as
being a good man that's what we because
i think it's a lot of pressure to put on
that's what i do but i just think i just
think things just like are
like i'm never gonna because when we're
saying we need to change society that's
just like you putting your world view on
to society and saying this is how you
should think
i don't do what i'm saying like like
because we have intern like like this is
what i mean when i say we feel shame
like that's that's a natural instinct
and there's a reason like everyone feels
the same like there's a reason men
respect the president of the united
states and look at that as a successful
man like there's a reason like women are
attracted to power ambition like some
stuff i don't think we can just
tell ourselves not to do it just like is
and i think for sure there's a certain
element of we
you know you can't always make someone
think the same way as you i can't
magically force the uae to be
progressive overnight i can't make them
respect women i can't change like i as
an individual can't help these things
and i completely understand that for
some societies some cultures they don't
want that they don't want me to come in
and be like well i think but without
things like that we'd still have fgm
being acceptable every year female
genital mutilation which is really
widespread especially in africa like and
the more that we talk about that and say
actually that's really not acceptable
and i know a lot of people make the
argument the fallacy of tradition we
talk about in philosophy the fallacy of
tradition it's like just because it's a
traditional thing doesn't mean it's a
good thing or the right thing or it
benefits people so i think there's it's
i think i think it's a give and take
thing i think it's a thing of no you
shouldn't force your world view and you
shouldn't force your opinion people are
entitled to their opinion but i think
sometimes it's like these things
actually aid people so i would never
want a man to think you know he has to
act this way because without the respect
of someone else and he cares really what
this guy thinks then he's less of a man
and if he's less of a man then who is he
like
do you think that's just like even when
you say like i don't want to say less of
a man because it's like
i just feel like that's like dishonest
like there's hierarchies in every just
like every society of life and you can't
say like pretend they don't exist
doesn't make them not exist so for
example like a victoria's secret model
is hotter than me and if you're going to
like come up to me and say like oh
you're just as high
you could say that
but that's that's life and it's the same
thing with like guys there's hierarchies
with like men in terms of like and
because a lot of it's like they men
value like other men like they pick it
like they they pick who they respect and
who they don't
like yeah i mean yeah there's there's
hierarchy in everything whether that's
attractiveness or your kind of social
standing and you see i was saying before
you see it so much in schools in terms
of popular kind of popularity groups and
i think it becomes more redundant when
you're in kind of day-to-day society but
i think the problem with this this thing
of what what makes a good man or what i
mean what makes a good woman
it's not only are they kind of two
different things but i think that
they're abstract and i think in the same
way we go what is our net what is what
is a great british value well i think
it's supply and demand it's like supply
like when we go to talk about a good man
and a good woman it's supply and demand
it's like who do the most men want who
do the most women want
you know
i just think goodness is is tied much
more to
who you are as a person and less about
okay what do other people think of you
and actually do you treat people nicely
i think that's right like a good man is
the same thing as what a good woman is
right but usually like i don't think
i think i think the original point was
just that he was i think
when he was saying more of a man
i think is what we would
call a good example of what a man could
be and is
part of that or what contributes to that
is him having a respectable partner or
a perceived respectable partner because
i keep using this because it's fresh but
like will smith he's a good man
but i don't think he's been respected
for a long time
yeah he's not been respected as a man
for a long time especially within his
relationship but he's a very good man i
just i just don't think putting
limitations especially on the situation
of like
and this is this isn't an attack on you
at all of what you said it's more just
like the phrasing of it makes me go like
oh because i think um not me you can say
it
i'm not me
it doesn't i encourage you to be a man
it doesn't make me think don't say it
it's more that i think um i think that
putting putting a limitation on your
partner in order to make you seem more
respectable is not necessarily healthy
well women do that to men though
that doesn't make it healthy
nah i i feel like
it um the the quality of the woman or
like for example if she has the only
fans just for like for example it does
affect you as a man for example
look at will smith right before before
we knew all the stuff we knew about jada
right
we thought will smith was like
top dude he was the man fresh we were
yeah his first prince on the show and
then in real life he was doing all these
movies and he was like will smith but
now
you look at will smith and you just
it's hard to see him the same but even
now if you're watching the next movie it
won't it won't hit the same as
before the whole
just just the slap himself
and the way he got mocked for that
that's one thing and then you got like
for some kanye
i don't know how many people was a kanye
documentary
but like he's a he's very good at what
he does like he's top tier
um and you can see like he has good
intentions he's good with his family but
kim
like he can't look at kanye the same
because
the way his wife moves or has moved in
the future because because it kind of
reflects the guy because it shows your
your discernment
that's it like because women like we
look for like men that have good
discernment because like when men are
more logical women are more emotional in
general so like when you pick a girl
that's a 304 like it shows a lack of
you've got katie price
yeah yeah like
she doesn't
stick with a guy and this goes back to
the the whole tendency thing and like
she had um
i could be wrong in it but it was i
think dwight was it dwight york her
first guy
okay she had a football guy a football
player and then she's been in other
relationship with peter andre yeah um
even recently she was um
she had a fiance
and that's that ended you know and it's
like
um
[Music]
it's just like
your wife is a reflection of your wife
or your girl's reflection of you and
like
she can either increase your value or
lower your value just depending on how
that's perceived
but i guess
so i guess i would i would i would
counter that with
these are also public figures and i feel
like that's a completely different
game to day-to-day life for people who
aren't famous i think life in the public
eye is a different thing entirely and
anyone who's in that public eye would
attest to that but i would also say that
i don't respect kanye not because he's
got with kim because if you hear her
speak for all of the like and i'm and
i'm the first one to be like look okay
these guys are really not the epitome of
role models that we should necessarily
hold up but not because i'm like oh she
made a sex tape or whatever if you hear
her speak in interviews she's really
intelligent and she's starting like look
at her she's built a multi-million pound
business yeah but she also ruined the
family
she left the faint like
she like she broke a home
and like that's four kids who now like
have to grow up without a dad in the
house
he like i don't know and i understand i
understand he's nuts but you picked him
like i'm sorry like he was crazy before
and like like
yeah like and that's what i'm saying
that's what happens when you like wife
at 304s they leave a lot of the time
like women leave 80 of the time in
divorce but this is the thing like i
would never have chosen kenya west in
the first place why would you have
chosen him but because he's like insane
like look at the way that he's in this
relationship oh like okay and i'm
talking i'm trying to be a housewife
i know that okay i know that he has
mental health problems like and i think
that is a struggle in and of itself do
you respect him but no and i didn't
respect him before like i didn't respect
him before
because like any time i heard him speak
i just thought what is this guy talking
about okay so he's chatting on so so
here's the thing right
you wouldn't choose a guy you don't
respect the only difference in what
we're saying
is that
how
what contributes to a man's respect is
different to what contributes to a
woman's respect
so like for example
like a woman is more respectful if she
like speaks very intelligently of course
and i don't disagree with you i think
she is a very intelligent person
but guys care more about how she acts
sexually
in terms of where the respect for her
comes whereas for women it might be okay
you may not care how he acts sexually
but you do care if he can articulate
himself you do care how intelligent he
is so i think
i think what we're trying to say is like
respect respect is important to everyone
it's just got what guys use to
measure a woman's respect we just use
different metrics than what you guys use
i guess i just i guess it i mean i guess
i just
i feel
slightly
maybe not baffled is the right word i
just think it's a bit of a shame because
i think that
like when we look at the case of will
and jada right i think
i think will's action will's action so i
was at a private like oscar's viewing
thing
and i just wrapped on a project and i
was sat there with this director and
we're chatting away whatever and i see
this happen on the screen and i thought
it was a stage punch did you
from the audience and i was like
this guy is pissed this guy's properly
pissed no one shells like that unless
they are [ __ ] red red with rage he's
an actor
no but but but but he wasn't even might
like listen as well he's not even miked
and i just went oh that man's pissed and
then i was going oh my god what just
happened before i just chatted through
the whole like punch thing or whatever
but i don't respect him because of the
like the what he did i don't think
that's uh i don't think that's good i
didn't you should assault comedians i
don't think that you should have sold
anybody and i also think as well it's
like okay this person tells jokes for a
[ __ ] living like do you know what i
mean even if i didn't agree with the
person and i thought that's not a funny
joke i took that personally it's not
gonna make me fight someone but i think
that people have a lot of opinions on
the will and jada thing because they see
that they have a history of i i'm not
sure if it was cheating or or pollyanna
it's because it's because of what jada
chose to put on red table talk
yeah this thing of like celebrity i find
it so strange i'm like but it's it's the
same thing if you if you like it might
happen on uh like the reason we look at
celebrities is because they represent
like our normal life
so like like for example i know a lot of
guys that have trouble in like custody
like getting custody of the kids and so
when kanye was going through that it
kind of represents like part of like a
problem in society because if a
billionaire can't get custody of his
kids like what what does that say about
society right same thing like if if you
wife a 304 that like talks
right on online it might not happen at
like a global scale but like you can
still embarrass your dude in your
community
you know what i'm saying like it might
it might not happen at that big of a
level but these people like they
represent what's happening in society
just at like a global scale does that
make sense yeah i suppose i just i
actually
respect them for the fact that um
i mean she wouldn't speak on it on a
podcast
unless he was happy for her to do so i
think we we could all agree that they
have a stable enough relationship you
think you think she listens
oh my god no she she just said that she
didn't agree with the slap no no no no
i'm saying is in i
when they talk about when she talks
about like the the kind of sexual
relationship that they have and like
their open relationship and things when
she's spoken on that right they had they
had
they had august on red table talk
who's august
the guy the guy that she essentially
cheated with like 20 years younger but
interesting i'll be honest i think jd is
going to do whatever she wants to do but
yeah i think my point is like i i
in a sense respect the fact that
these people
regardless of what people think of jada
because i think she
gets a lot of flack i don't know all of
the insider goss by the way i'm up at
the other yeah but
i think that i respect them for the fact
that will is a is is clearly standing up
and saying actually you know we have
this kind of relationship or you know
we've we've had a bit of an open
relationship and i still love my wife
and things and i think okay fair enough
regardless of what i think of the
dynamic of your relationship i
appreciate the fact that that this
person is going i still stand with my
wife i think that's
i think that's that's a good thing but i
think
you know like going back to the original
point i think that
i think it's just a i think it's just a
bit of a shame that like that that we've
you how
like the the way that we
view our respect of men versus women
that it's that it's not a similar thing
in the in our respect of men is is
deemed on you know respectable things
like you know
are you intelligent
you know are you ambitious these good
qualities and women are reduced down to
have you slept with lots of men well
it's not reduced down to it's like
that's easier
you know much harder it is to be a dude
you just have to not get fat okay as a
girl not get fat not sleep with too many
people and you'll you'll find a husband
but like men if they want to get a woman
they have to make a lot of money they
have to go to the gym they have to like
there's a long list of [ __ ] that like
women look for
i think guys do too and i think it's i
think as we move away that's not true
that's not true no because statistically
like like if you if you survey women
like i could point out study after study
after study showing you that's not true
because if you look at dating app swipes
men swipe right like 50 of the time and
on top of that like they serve it men if
you go on a first date with a girl she
has 80 of the things you look for would
you go on a second date men said yes
women said no like women are pickier
it's much harder for a man to like get
girls than it is for girls to get guys
even even as even in commitment terms
yeah i think in terms of on the surface
level of
what do people want and again going back
to that thing of abundance yeah but i
think
every guy i know every single res like
guy who i go oh we're friends we're
these are these are guys who i really
respect
none of them like of course they could
go okay i would maybe swipe right on her
but none of them would stay if she had
no personality no ambition no hobbies no
interest
sure a guy a guy with options you're
correct like the guys that can will but
like my point is
like we're complaining about this double
standard right but it's like
it's not even that bad
to be honest it might like i think it's
a much harder for men on the other end
because they have to like build up to be
something that women want unless you're
just born really good looking and tall
when you came to my channel you said
when you're dating apps like
you look at most of the girls you go oh
yeah like with most girls you can see
something attractive that you go yeah
i'd go on a date with you you look at
the guys and you're like most guys
you're like what the [ __ ] is this you
even said that so it's like
and
so here's a question do you think you
apply a different standard to men than
you do to women
when you're dating them
no i think it's a thing of am i
do they have a good personality are they
physically attractive i look for the
same things the same traits
but i think my my point when we were
speaking before is i think there are
objectively more pretty women in the
world than there are good-looking man so
do you like a guy who's taller than you
and we also spoke about this and i again
i've dated people who were sure like
someone who was actually shorter than me
and i've dated people who are all [ __ ]
than me well what like would you prefer
a guy who's taller
oh come on don't cap like what i mean is
imagine you've got the guy he's got
amazing personalities right
there's one version of him where he's
six foot one and there's one version of
him when he's five foot four
who are you gonna choose
that's actually that's a really
interesting question are you saying it
has no bearing i actually don't know no
i actually don't know do you care if a
girl is taller than you i actually
prefer girls who are taller than me yeah
you do i actually prefer taller girls
yeah have you dated more you're in luck
yeah i tend to prefer girls who are
taller than me maybe i would with guys
say that maybe if there was a side by
side i don't think and i don't think
it's a bad thing because you know i've
got quite a few friends who are bi as
well and it's like
they they probably they apply a
different standard to men they do for
women
and i think ugly i would agree i do i i
would say there's more attractive girls
than guys yeah
um
but there is a burden there is a higher
burden of performance on men
in terms of
to in terms of being attractive in
general in comparison to women find 80
of men unattractive
yeah i can i can relate to that yeah do
you find 80 of women unattractive
no but then i feel like my attraction to
women is
how do i put this but do you do you see
what i'm saying when i'm saying like
it's much harder for men in dating
like in just like oh like yeah
for sure in terms of like and again
talking about like abundance and things
like that i think because if there are
all of these pretty women and i think
they go oh my god he's the he's the top
guy
i think for sure but i think again a lot
of that is reducing it down to dating
but then so then could you understand
like when men like really don't have a
ton of standards that it's okay like
like that they might say like that
that's a standard for them is that
either a low body count or no only fans
yeah and again like i completely i'm
like if that's if that for you is a deal
breaker i respect that that's fine
you're allowed to have that opinion
but for me it's just more about
but why do you have that opinion one in
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the last year i think
that's under
those isn't it
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the past year
that's brutal yeah that's brutal
i'm going to read some super chats
really quick
okay okay um
let's see
sammy oh here i brought it to the table
for you yeah
oh it's not golden
[Laughter]
oh i don't care um
okay um let's see
max
shot
max sax
okay
um the risk doesn't make sense you're
paying the highest price for a woman
with a history of accepting the lowest
bid often from men that rank lower than
yourself by standards that matters to
men and other men actually that's an
interesting question is like would you
rather a girl's ex be better than you or
worse than you
well i want to be the best she's ever
gone okay
five dollars from the uk economist
remember the legacy parents leave behind
can like their legacy parents leave
behind can haunt their kids imagine
their teens bullied at school for their
moms only fans five dollars from wesley
anderson social constructs don't always
adhere to reality
um okay
perfect
that's all i've done
going back to
her point as well i feel like
um wall smith found like jaden two packs
a great example because you have one guy
who's like very successful
he
um
famous actor he's done his thing like
every girl's one of them since like the
90s what not at worst you get two pack
he's also quite successful as well but
like i thought back in the day
there was a there was a matchup but will
what was it slightly higher but yet jada
still has feelings for tupac to this day
so it's more so it's a bit more deeper
to how successful you are and how much
money you are like he's a great guy
and whatnot but still she still edges
two pack over him kind of thing so it's
quite hard for guys to
to be competing even if you're quite
actually i have a question as guys do
you think that women like choose the
best guys like if like if you
if you looked at the like the guys on
your your friends or your team or
whatever that like
that the women pick like do you think
girls pick the best guys best guys in
general best guys for them a few sister
have you had a sister
oh yeah no no
no
what do you what kind of guys do you
think girls pick
depends how old they are depends it
depends that that
like i said it's just the energy really
like if you come with if you come with
them
and and they're really digging a vibe
then they're most likely to pick you but
then at the same time it it like they're
not really looking at
like how much money you're making or or
what you're really doing it's just
really the way you're coming out that's
why like a girl could go with a broke
guy
for a period of time without even
realizing his broke after a while so
yeah
now i think um
girls go with the most popular like the
most trending guy who's
who's um who's got the most clout around
them and um just a couple days ago i
think maybe even yesterday i was
watching i think on twitter and i was
talking about how russell wilson was
getting like
ashamed and roast not not shane but like
okay clown for being like a square or
like just like a lame guy
and he's actually like a really good guy
yeah he is
i watched the thing when when he talked
about he he went on the podcast as well
and he talks about
um
what he said on his first date with
sierra
and he talked about his um she asked him
about his wallet and his wallet was like
beat up old wallet and he said um that
shows um consistency like he's a
consistent guy like he's reliable
um because he hasn't changed his wallet
like it's the same one that he's he's
stuck by with he could have got a new
one didn't
and you know we i say we but popular
culture look at so um future for example
and he's like glorified and everything
but if you put them
next to each other in terms of
just rating them
russell wilson is more of a desirable
guy man than the future but he's just
the future is more
popular he's more he's more out there so
girls will gravitate to him more
he's he's he's a more desirable guy for
long term
i would say long time russell wilson for
sure yeah but for short term
i think it's probably funny you think
girls girls are more attracted to future
is what you're saying but they're more
than younger girls who aren't looking
for
long-term prospects yeah i feel like
depends where it is really like say if
it was a social setting
and then you you had like the rich like
popular cool guys at the corner and then
you just had like let's say like the
regular guys but they're on vim
and they're they're some of them i don't
know what theirs so if it means like
you're coming up with good energy like
you're you're actually expressing
yourself and you're letting them know
how you're feeling really where it's
like the boujee the boujee guys who who
obviously have clout yeah they're kind
of chilling because like they're like
they're chilled yeah right yeah more
times like in that sort of situation
like from experience i've seen they
would they would rather go for the loss
less popular guy just just based off
them just off the muscle because they
know where they stand
exactly yeah i hear that what about okay
do you guys think that men choose the
best women
like
based on your friends like the girls
they go after do you think they go after
like quality women or do you think they
go after three or fours
it depends
i don't know but what you would define
like it's up to your interpretation
like i've seen my my friends as soon as
they they're within a nine out of ten or
ten out of ten they just crumble
automatically they're just soft boys
yeah so yeah
i've noticed there's a certain type of
guy that i swear likes girls that are a
little bit mean to them i don't know
what it is yeah
i think that's the same with girls
though too yeah oh first nagging is a
very very real thing for sure
what do you think
what about do guys choose the best girls
yeah what do you think
if he has options yes if he doesn't then
he won't okay
from the environment i've been in i've
got to be careful with what i said
are you friends he's watching right now
who's watching right now the environment
i've been in and the stuff i've seen
guys do choose the best girl in the end
but
in a particular like period where things
are active
you're going for like the baddest or the
most fun yeah
yeah but when it comes to settling down
[Music]
the the family aspect they choose the
one that's right and i just have said
i've just seen that just
hear me i've seen it
i have a question okay
for the gentleman in the room yeah um
so you you were saying about the women
in your life you don't sometimes you
don't think they choose the right man
what what what is it for you what is it
that that women in our lives yeah so she
was so so you guys said like women don't
always like they might pick future over
the other guy yeah
pearl said you know do you think that
the women in your life choose the best
men
and you said no
what for you then then
quantifies or qualifies the best man if
they're picking who who is it that
they're picking
versus what uh versus who you think they
should pick what what what are the
distinguishing characteristics in your
own words uh i would say a guy who's
gonna prof he's gonna provide security
for her emotionally physically and
financially
and i bet the guy who can best do that
all three
in my opinion is the best is the better
choice
because thing is the futures of the
world they're not providing that
emotional security for you
probably not me they might provide the
physical one if you're if if you're
there but how often is he going to be
with you like once every two weeks every
day
every two weeks
um so that's what i would say the one
the one who
can do all those three in a good good
standard to be honest
oh um
yeah mainly what he said that they just
prioritized like um the girls feelings
emotional security what not
not too much on the uh financials
stability-wise but obviously it'll be
nice if they're financially stable but
like the other two would be more of a
priority um
pretty much the same what they said just
knowing how this
he's he's trustworthy like
the things that needs to get done he
gets it done
and
i feel like we've again
you know you just know you know and
we've all said it here and and so would
you say the same for
women then are these also not things you
would want in terms of someone who's em
financially stable and and
is emotionally
uh intelligent and can be there for you
emotionally and and offer that stability
and who is also trustworthy would you
say that's a universal thing do you
think that's that's the same for women
too not exactly well i don't emotional
security yes
i don't think guys look to women for
physical security to be honest yeah i
don't think guys look to women for
financial security i don't think most
guys do are you saying that
men
don't care that i can deadlift a lot oh
no they'll care if you can
because if you're taller than most guys
they're definitely looking for you to
be physically secure for them yeah i
want that no
i've seen your bench press is quite
heavy as well
thank you
i will jump i would jump in here and say
so i was a team gb power lifter
and so i will say yes like and
yeah man but like it's interesting to
see how men react to that like to do
with the strength thing i think for a
lot of guys they're like yo they feel
like i've seen you somewhere
really yeah because team g power that
makes sense right but um
i i think for it's interesting to see
how guys react that this is definitely a
side tangent but like it is really
interesting to see how guys react to
that because it's like oh you know
you're like you're strong and [ __ ] you
can look after yourself before that i
did emma um not mma i don't think guys
really care do you think they can i
don't i don't i don't think i don't
think i think they think it's cool
because i think they go oh that's you
is it cool to you that i can bench a lot
is it like is it i find it different but
i come from a powerlifting background
and it's but um i've seen like a lot of
my friends back in like college and
whatnot they were quite skinny and they
didn't used to hit jim and they talked
about how uh if a girl had a bit of
strivation so they're a bit of muscle
automatically they're just cancelled
they just look at him uh yeah yeah oh
wow no i've heard that too that's like
so it depends on the sort of guy really
yeah
i think it's sex sexual security i think
i think that's something maybe these
guys just
i just think guys like girls in shape
right
yeah a girl who looks after herself yeah
yeah and she doesn't well
she doesn't have to have like a six-pack
or anything like that like but
just a girl who looks after herself
especially if he looks after himself
do you know what i mean
[Music]
what is the biggest red flags you guys
see in girls
she doesn't offer to pay her share on
the first date i disagree with you on
that
i think that's a good red flag
i don't think that's that big of a deal
she doesn't offer to pay on a first date
no because she's not entitled to my time
all my money yeah but sometimes guys
just offer to pay no no fight you for it
it's good though
it's good that a guy pays but i'm saying
it's
the lack of gesture is a red flag
the lack of gesture yeah because it goes
away sometimes i just feel really
awkward i'm gonna be honest sometimes
i'm like my guy so let's say you see a
girl yeah yeah and you turn and you
asked her to come on a date with you yep
you took her
out of her own space i didn't take her
anywhere she chose to come i hear that
thank you she was chilling like she
wasn't that that wasn't happening um
thank you she's not gonna she's not
gonna say yes if she doesn't wanna come
yeah she wanted to come but she wasn't
gonna ask him so he asked her all right
what i'm saying is
is you're you see a girl that you like
yep and you ask her
[Music]
she should then also pay no no i didn't
say she should pay i said she should she
should offer no no she should offer to
pay her share
if i when i if i take girl if i ask a
girl out on a date
i'm always going to pay
but i want her to offer to pay her [ __ ]
that's what i was getting there i was
just making sure that
that was the main thing you'd always
want to pay because you took it out yeah
but you just want to see like
if she would help out too
it's a la it's for me it's just showing
it's it's a sign of appreciation she's
like
you don't have to do this for me
but i appreciate when you do
because she the things that she will do
that she doesn't have to do for me but
i'll appreciate like
if she
i know she cooks for me so it's not i'm
not like oh because you're a woman you
have to do that so i'm like oh thanks
baby if i was super thankful and i was
like oh that's so nice like thank you so
much you would still think i was like
entitled
uh
because most guys just grab it no if
that's what i'm saying yeah saying thank
you okay like being being appreciative
okay i'm not gonna fight you for it i
won't no but i'd be like oh no i don't
mind if you spit this all right no it's
okay
there you go okay great thanks but i do
i'm not gonna go quick then we're like
let me i'm okay great
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to you i
do like you asked me no but it's just
it's just about it's just about it's
just about being polite it's just about
being polite that's how i say thank you
that's still polite yeah that's all
right that's all right
okay glad to know i wouldn't get i
wouldn't get sent packing
i don't say thank you but like if she
doesn't even say she doesn't offend she
doesn't even say thank you i i know the
vibe no way i'm taking you out again i
know i know the vibe you're talking
about i get it i'm not saying
my bad it's okay there's always this
happens sorry this happens i i think if
i think though if you if you start to
say that you think that um
women should pay half which by the way i
always think which is not what i'm
saying no no but i'm saying if you
expect a woman to at least offer even if
you say no
um i think then does that not imply that
you also talking back to the
expectations of what you want from a
woman does that then not just say you
don't just want a woman who's pretty and
in shape you now want a woman who is
financially stable because no it's poor
yeah and polite but no but if a woman
wasn't financially stable she would not
offer because if you said yeah all right
and then she's like sure i've got no
money in my bank account but i think
it's the polite would you agree like
it's because you want her to be polite
yeah i think i think if i'm being honest
i think part of it is maybe i think i'm
maybe a bit more uh sensitive to that
because the way i've been raised is to
always be grateful when think people do
things
so i think for me that's quite important
we were talking about this the other day
i'm like i think it's bad that i prefer
like just hanging out over dates oh yeah
you talk about that today yeah yeah
that you would rather just like invite a
guy but it's not a good thing i'm like i
should like
coaching you absolutely not i know
because more because i'm lazy and so i'm
like
i'm like i gotta go downtown
i get put off if like say
i've met someone
online or in person and they're like oh
like without eddie uh um that they don't
provoked it or they just go oh so um
where are you taking me to
like it it's a trigger for me internet
like as soon as that said i don't want
to take out no more because like you
kind of expect me to just take out and
then all of a sudden pay you like a
cinderella kind of thing if that makes
sense
especially on an app oh my god that's
gonna keep the first date first date i'm
not trying to go out to like dinner
because what if okay what if i match
with you on an app okay
and you start sending me weird stuff you
know what i mean like
like or like didn't you go out with him
would you well no i wouldn't but like i
meant like when i get there oh i said
sending sorry wrong word wrong word but
like what if i get there and like it's
weird like then i how am i going to
leave before i had dinner you know what
i mean
you're like am i supposed to go hungry
yeah that's that's why we have ask for
angela in england have you seen if
you've ever been i was going to say if
you've ever been in women's toilets you
probably haven't but um there's a they
always have to sing on the back saying
ask for angela so you can ask at the
back and you say oh is angela working
and they'll provide you a taxi back home
if you've got a date that's going south
really
yeah never known that yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you've got
if you've got a date that's going south
and part of it is from a protection
point of view if this person is giving
you vibes of like this person is
potentially going to kidnap me and i
could end up buried in a ditch somewhere
but also if it's free
i don't know see i don't think i think
if i think if it's a case of if you ask
i think like a bargain
[Laughter]
i think it's probably at the pub's
discretion but i would imagine that it's
not free if you were just like oh i'm
just really not having a great i'm just
you know what i'm not feeling i know but
i could be like could you take me in my
day
i'm just saying i'm just i'm asking for
angela i grew up with a very cheap dad
okay
i love me a bargain
all right well i yeah
all right question for the ladies what's
uh what's a red flag
for you that you you see in a guy first
impressions
red flag
if he tries to show me his mixtape
i used to i used to do i used to do rap
reactions so people used to oh really
no no i'm i'm like seriously but like
some rapper who's you've done that with
is watching this like what the [ __ ]
no
in it
no no um it's a real red flag um
i would say like if they're talking
about their past relationships and like
everything is the girl's fault or like
the girl's crazy
i'm like okay so either you like crazy
women okay
which isn't that's not good
i'm like then offensive why are you out
with me
or two or two like like you probably
cheat like because in my mind it's like
oh he's probably a cheater because
why are all these girls going crazy like
because i have brothers they date
and their girlfriends don't go crazy on
them because they're not cheaters i
don't do that i have a question you said
something interesting like
you're like oh the second thing
is that he's probably a cheater because
he made them crazy
if it's a pattern one off that's one
thing but if it's a pattern you're the
common denominator right but
but why would you
why would you say
that if they're all crazy
it's because of him why is that even an
option why because i would say the same
thing for a girl so you say if a girl
was like to you like every guy i've been
with has been abusive to me you'd be
like well what the [ __ ] did you do yes i
swear to god yes yes
i mean i'm not gonna say to her face but
i'm thinking it like what did you do
like i just wanna i just wanna clarify
if you go through life and you have the
same patterns in all of your
relationships like how can you not
just i just want to clarify right
because this might get you some in some
hot water okay okay
you're saying that there's a possibility
that if a girl gets abused it's her own
fault
yeah because some girls some girls
attack the guys first no no yeah if she
gives you i know but so so if it's
either like there's either two issues
with her she's either she picks guys
that are abusers why are you picking men
that are it's the same thing i would say
the same way why are you picking men
that are abusers because and like i've
been in like a bad relationship before
where like i would say he was crazy it
was my own damn fault like
what was not every relationship but like
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like you should take accountability for
who you pick no i agree no i i agree
with you yeah but like you said that was
the first option right so the first
option you're like okay
clearly he's choosing wrong yeah then he
said the second option you're like oh
he's triggered them to behave this way
yeah and you think that's a thing yes i
think like
yeah like if a guy
can trigger if a guy if a guy's cheated
on every single girl that he's been like
like of course they're gonna act crazy
and i do i think like i think the girl
should probably just leave but as a
woman like we kind of know that like
like what are you doing
i disagree with that i don't think i
know there's this whole thing of you
know women are
you know generally more emotional than
men
but
this whole thing of being like when a
girl goes
oh he made me crazy or he made her crazy
i just think that's just massive
[ __ ] like you are
you're control you're in control of your
own actions and you can you can leave
the environment you can leave the
situation i i agree
i like i agree with you like i think in
an ideal world like you should leave but
that doesn't always happen because i
just think guys can't use that excuse oh
well she just made me crazy so i decked
her in the throat like guys oh but i
wasn't talking about decking in the
throat that's like when i
when i thought crazy i just thought like
she's always asking where i am or like
she's looking through my phone that's
what i was thinking i wasn't oh no i
never i would never crazy like she's
like thrown [ __ ] cuz oh no i would never
never never in a million years advocate
like that that's something okay
so it is your ability to pick though
yeah it is 100
oh no i was gonna say i would jump in
here and say literally i was like
literally i could have kissed you right
then
that um that that is equally what i
would say the red flag for me if a guy
says his girlfriend is like specifically
psycho [ __ ] those are literal words
i've heard before always it's always the
guys that cheat it's always always
that's always
the cheat but it's always and this is
the thing man does something wrong woman
holds him accountable woman is then a
psycho [ __ ] and like that isn't the
trend sometimes sometimes the one thing
i would say
is like
the i so i agree with the first part of
what you said i would disagree with the
latter part about to do with sometimes
it's the woman's fault if someone or
like is the person's fault if they're
being abused i would say for sure do you
think it's their fault for picking them
like it's the same pattern for sure i
would say that sometimes people have a
pattern of picking abusers but i think a
lot of the time people who have been
raised in abusive
surroundings i'm just that thing because
that is what the and i think sometimes i
think people sometimes people are really
deceptive there have been cases of
marrying someone who as soon as they're
married they completely
i've just found those like if there's a
pattern of behavior like a lot of times
like girls won't talk about what they
did first
so like yeah maybe he like did something
but like
that i never would advocate for a guy to
hit well
yeah
don't even look it for girls watching
this she's very cute
that's a
big
if a girl is threatening a guy with a
wife a knife or something like that
that's what i was thinking okay okay
yeah yeah that's all right that's what i
was thinking like like if if a girl
is your thing shut up
but then we're talking about but then
we're talking about a woman who's
instigating abuse because they're being
abusive
but i think why do we assume that like
the woman like she could have started it
okay yeah she could have by being
abusive in the first place right in case
we're not talking about domestic abuse
victims but we're talking about someone
in a in a right equally toxic and
abusive relationship i think it can be
both i think yeah that's definitely a
thing but i think it's dangerous
territory territory to wander into the
well maybe she maybe it's justified
maybe she deserved it and i think or
maybe he deserved it or maybe he
deserves it yeah yeah yeah this is also
another thing of of women there was a
really good documentary on the bbc i
mean i think you have to question like
people that bring that stuff forward
like either way like if they're going to
press charges or something they have to
like question that yeah you have to you
of course you have to look at all the
evidence yeah i guess i just come from a
standpoint of
i've seen women who have been in those
relationships yeah and nine times out of
ten more than nine times out of ten 99
of the time it's genuinely that you know
they've not held a knife to their guy's
throat and again i think this is where
the physical dominance comes into a
relationship of like i am intrinsically
always going to feel more vulnerable
around like it take you for example all
right you are way taller than me okay
physically okay regardless of my
strength my strength training
historically
you could overpower me so easily like
and i think guys know that in a
relationship with a woman you're an
idiot if you don't and women are aware
of that in a relationship and i think it
it starts to wander into dangerous
territory when we start to say um
did they do something to deserve this
and where do we draw the line with that
do we draw the line with that with rape
did they do something to deserve this
did they instigate it in some way yeah
but like that's you have to like the
police have to also do you know because
you can't give someone the power to just
and i think it's actually the same thing
in society like you have to question
people when they bring something forward
because you don't ever want to give
someone this like the power to ruin
someone's reputation with just accusing
them of something that could have been
completely false there has to be
evidence yeah you you have to
investigate it i guess my point is where
does that line of questioning come from
and where does that bleed into society
does it come from a point of because i
intrinsically disbelieve you because all
women are trying to ruin men's lives or
does it come from a point of i need to
know this evidence because i'm a
prosecutor well it's innocent until
proven guilty yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you realize like society favors women
like they say believe all women even
though women be crazy
like no i'm saying like there are crazy
girls that lie about [ __ ] and like ruin
men's lives like they go to jail or even
if they don't do that like a girl can
ruin a guy's reputation with just an
accusation okay but look at look at the
amount of men okay within england i
think it's something like one percent
of uh of reported uh sexual assault
crimes get get taken
uh to be prosecuted by this by the cps
by the crown prosecution service it's
something like one percent right because
you need evidence yeah yeah yeah and
they asked for very substantial
very very substantial evidence in order
to prosecute it because they're like
that's a lot of money to invest in it i
can understand it but it's hard to prove
that yeah and then they also then from
taking it to court it's such a low
percentage that actually get proven true
and a lot of the time it's because
you're assuming but you're assuming
right now like your automatic assumption
is that all those people are like
telling the truth right like all the
because you don't know what percentage
of the people that came forward with
that stuff we're telling the truth and
what we're lying and i'm not saying like
we know either way but like
you can't know
no you can't i would equally say that i
think we view this so completely
differently than like any other crime if
someone said i was burgled you don't see
you don't see guys going um you or you
don't smile saying like well you know
innocent until proven jesus
his fingerprints were found at the crime
scene there is video evidence here of
him doing it yeah
innocent until proven guilty
also i would like to say i don't know a
single woman who has ever lied about
being assaulted but i know so many women
who have okay can i
so i will say two things i've got a
story
personally about a woman lying about me
um but the other thing i was going to
say is that like it it you are writing
those stats but it's because sexual
assault is very hard to prove with
evidence like they they apply the same
standard of there has to be substantial
evidence in other cases like for example
like do you know how many people get
convicted for stealing cars
it's like less than one percent because
it's so hard to prove because once a car
is gone it's gone yeah so i don't i i
completely hear what you're saying but
it's like it's not
it's because it and unfortunately it is
very hard to prove
um
when i was back in training
in drama school
um and
first term you know everyone's having
fun and everything right and i remember
there was this girl
who we were like flirting in class and
everything and stuff was happening
anyway
she asked me this was friday she was
like oh are you going to so-and-so's
party tonight and i was like yeah she's
like okay i'll see you there so i was
like all right cool i was like maybe
she's feeding me or this
go to the party i see her for a bit and
then i don't really see her throughout
the night
we're leaving the party right i'm
leaving i'm about to go home
and i see her outside with her housemate
and she's like oh kit um she's like
where you how you doing i was like yeah
i'm good you have a good time yeah she's
like what are you doing now i'm just
gonna get on the night bus home she's
like oh well why don't you
stay with me at mine i live around the
corner
i was like okay i was like i hadn't
really seen her throughout the whole
party so i was like i didn't think
anything of it so we get back to hers
and she
one of my friends was a roommate of hers
and he wasn't staying there that night
so i was just like okay i'll just stay
in his room like because i really see
that i didn't think anything of it and
then she was like oh
um why don't you stay in my bed i was
like
all right
cool so i go to the toilet
i come out
she's basically stripped naked in the
bed and she's like oh come give me a
cuddle i was like all right
so i was like okay so i kind of stripped
down to our boxes giving her naked
cuddle and stuff but obviously you know
i just started kissing the back of her
neck started trying initiating stuff and
she wasn't really kind of reciprocating
i was like oh like
i was like do you
she was like
i was i was like oh do you not want to
like you're not tempted whatever and she
was like ah she was like basically like
i just um there's this guy that i kind
of started seeing i really want to see
how it goes
and i was like
okay
and i was like ah i thought she was
joking i was like oh really she's like
no yeah like i just kind of really like
i don't want to mess it up or anything
so i was like
okay and i'll be honest like i was
pissed off because i felt massively led
on i was like i was going home why did
my own business and you invited me back
to yours or whatever
and you basically asked me to give you a
naked cuddle but i was like you know
fine whatever
turned around went to sleep in the
morning i left i didn't even say
anything
fast forward two years
i'm on holiday with group of my friends
a really close female friend of mine and
she goes we're in spain and she goes kip
you know i'm gonna say the name in case
they watch this they're like you know um
so and so i was like oh yeah she was
like you know because something happened
between you and her in first year i was
like yeah she was like you like what
happened so i told you a story i just
told you she was like yeah that makes
that like
definitely makes more sense for who i
know that you are and i was like why
what did you hear
apparently she had gone around telling
everyone that i tried to force myself
onto her
b man
that's what happened mate
i cannot tell you the [ __ ] rage oh my
god your audacity
and i found this out two years did you
say something to her no
has anything like that ever has that
ever happened to you guys
and i was like imagine if that came out
now
yeah that would ruin
my everything right that like i know
it's purely anecdotal but i think it's
and i'll be honest she's not even a bad
person like she's not a psycho girl
she's like a regular pretty girl
right mm-hmm
and i just didn't expect that mm-hmm and
i found that out two years later
like you just wouldn't so i'm not saying
this happens all the time but what i'm
trying to say is that the reason i
shared that story is because
it's not the crazy girl who you think
yeah she'd make out and because she was
like your average girl and she was just
sick now she may have not meant it
maliciously at the time but that could
have made me an ass massively well and
nobody questioned her because like
that's what i'm like nobody said okay
well how did that happen you don't like
ask those questions well she's just
spreading this like around like that's
what she told the girls apparently well
it sounds like um
thank you by the way for sharing that
because stuff like that as well is like
it's very difficult as someone who has
been through abuse sexual assault
multiple times it's very difficult to
share that but i can also appreciate
it's very difficult to share with
someone with a group with the internet
with whoever
like someone accusing you of this
um so thank you but also just being
honest
but
it sounds like this this female friend
who came to you did the right thing but
also it sounds like people had
concerns or at least were kind of going
did this actually happen well especially
because like in the in the two years i
didn't hear anything about it and i'd
you know been involved with other people
so
like i don't know how much of it went
around and stuff but um
so i had something smart i had someone
on the
at my college i just found this out like
a month or two ago that he was telling
everyone we hooked up and i was like
i've never even kissed you like i'm so
confused oh [ __ ] and i was like
no but this is what happened like he
snapped me i remembered him like trying
like snapping me and i literally told
him he's like can i come over and i was
like no and he's like why and i was like
because i don't want to sleep with you
like and he was like oh thanks for
making that clear
and i was like
and so now i'm like this is like four
years later i'm like
what what did he say
but i don't know
it's people are weird
i've had that happen before with guys
which is quite funny
me and my friend were talking about this
before me and me and me and a female
friend me and a female friend who did
end up hooking up me and this girl and
the whole male group was salty because
they had all tried moves on me and i was
like nah i'm not interested you guys are
pagans like but i've had that before and
they're
like they were like and they had tried
it and they'd all gone like yeah what
was like i'll go with them
i was like it's not like if it was true
i'd be like yeah like you would have
heard about it probably from me like
like really
do you know why guys say that though
because like in our social group
like guys who were like
for example your name is emily i said
like
yeah i saw you talking to emily emily
yeah like on that spot there
[Music]
you can't edit but it's hard to be like
nothing happens
it's easier to realize
they won't even
explicitly say it they'll just insinuate
no but this guy i didn't even like i was
saying that's not okay though i had
never even hung out with him one-on-one
that's what i was confused
what's that what's that guy putting
i think it's jay he's always chatting
[ __ ] he's always like yeah yeah like i'm
such a player as long as you give me a
five as long as you give me a five star
review like honestly for real as long as
you were like yeah and she was great i'm
like all right to be fair i respect the
hustle
well i think it was because though i
find this out years later because i was
interested in his friend
and so but his friend like wouldn't talk
to me because he said he thought and i
was like
no
i don't like him but i respect the play
i was like what the hell oh yeah no i
have to agree with that because that was
like one of the most clear i have ever
been to a dude like because sometimes
you're nice but i wasn't even like
no i was just like look never
like you slept with like five of my
friends i don't want to be six like what
are you talking about
but yeah i have to agree with them um
going back to the fact that girls
girls do pick that crazy guys because i
feel like girls they just they just love
taking all the red flags they see the
red flags this is the first date and
then they're like nah like
it was just a fluke or something and the
next few you know he's now slapping you
up but then you saw this like since the
first minute of the day
kind of thing but then
guys are picking crazy girls i feel like
most i've been in a situation where when
i first met the girl she was she was
completely fine everything was stable
and then save three months in
i don't know what happened like what did
you do that's the real question no
what i told you
i've just been paid me the whole time
but just cause nothing's changed
and this goes back to the fact where um
when i was asking oh like would it
matter if
um
he wanted to see you every two weeks if
you start from two weeks because like
what i realized is a lot of girls would
not want that and then all of a sudden
they start acting crazy like oh you're
definitely doing this
i've been doing this since the beginning
i don't know
well yeah
yeah what do you think do you think
women like red flags
okay i mean i can attest to the fact
that i've seen red flags before and been
like
i don't know what that is
is that red now i think it's white i
think is it green i think it's green
yeah maybe i'm just kind of like you
know why that is i feel like for sure
but i would say that like because i
think sometimes you get wrapped up in
someone right sometimes you're like no
you see the red flag you're like nah no
i get i could tell you this i can tell
you the scientific really reason behind
it it's because the same traits that
make like the person the villain are the
same that make him like the hero yeah so
it's like like a guy that um
like is abusive let's just say it's the
same guy that can protect you
so it's like the same traits like a guy
that's super disagreeable like they tend
to make more money but they also tend to
be [ __ ] yeah so it's like it's like
uh
i forgot what they call they come like
the dark triad traits
what if you can't dress i kind of like
my man a little cheap
i
because i'm cheap like when it comes to
like because i just don't understand
like why you be spending all this money
on like clothes like i don't get it
interesting yeah because i would say
that style doesn't like i wouldn't look
at you and go
it's not real gucci
i mean i'd morby like it's fake gucci
care about that though i know a lot of
girls that care about how how a guy
dresses i would say i'm more than enough
how you put it together
yeah yeah yeah so i i like i like a guy
with style and and this is not even it
doesn't have to be my style i like
someone who's gone i've put thought into
my outfit because i put thought into
what i wear and i think it's nice if
someone makes an effort even if it's
like you know like i'm not normally
saying you would go for like the
turtleneck tailored wool coat look but
if i see someone repping that i'm like
yeah that's hot a suit a suit can do
wonders for a guy like what is it
like
is the equivalent of like
i don't know like a sexy like a sexy red
dress on a girl or like i don't know but
yeah for sure like i swear a suit brings
up a guy like at least a point yeah at
least i think part of it as well is
because the tailored cut of the suit is
like if you've got like a bit of a belly
or whatever like it goes over that
because especially a really nice
tailored suit like the structuring of
that i started off in film i started off
doing costuming jobs and styling jobs
and things so it's like oh man like if
someone is styled well i'm like sir you
thought about your outfit today and i
appreciate that but i would but but
going back to the point of red flags um
crocs are a red flag no um
no if uh if if uh
i think for sure there's been points
when i've run like
i think i think i've for sure been in
situations before when i've seen
something that's problematic and i think
sometimes you either downplay it because
you're like
maybe i'm overreacting
which is for sure a thing because you
kind of almost gaslight yourself and i
think that's definitely a thing i think
that's the thing as well for for women i
don't know if that's so much thing for
men but for women definitely kind of
going i just am i am am i overthinking
this am i thinking about too much am i
being a bit weird
but i think in general the the trend
that i've had relationship to
relationship
is that i go okay
i identified that red flag and now when
i see that in potential partners
now i go
yeah i've seen that red flag before
don't want that again like and there's
different things and it's to varying
degrees sometimes reflects come out of
nowhere but i think um i think sometimes
yeah i think and i think that's another
thing is as you go through more and more
relationships and as you get older and
more mature i think you get better at
seeing them identifying them and they're
not falling again again guys felons have
30 percent more kids than non-felons
case closed on women's picking skills
no surprise i literally tell my dad i'm
like dad you can literally pick my
husband i swear to god like
i know i swear i
i've told my dad this so many times but
he wants nothing to do with that he's
like because if it goes wrong you'll
blame me
i was thinking about this the other day
because i was thinking what who would
who would my parents pick for me and i
was trying to think would they pick
someone good or would they pick him up
no
they'd pick a square but that's who like
you should pick
good square would they pick a square
that i'd be like i can respect this
because i don't mind a square you know
right i'm not out here trying to tell
him i literally told my dad i was like
dad i swear to god i want to get married
and you can't you can
go hat but he said no well he would have
picked for you guys like your parents
would have picked feet up my dad well no
my dad he'd have to understand he like
hates people for one
and like for two he just like he's i
have nine siblings there's ten of us so
he's just like like you're 25 leave me
alone yeah
and third of all he doesn't he's like no
you make your own choices and deal with
the decisions like don't put this on me
because the thing is like i know that
for you too either your mama or grandma
or uncles that are if you've come back
to nigeria gonna i got a wife's land up
for you
i wish i wish so my aunt is like that my
i live with my aunt my aunt is so like
that she's literally like yeah yeah like
any any any any guy or girl who walks
through the door she's like she is
trying she's trying to set me up for
life literally if she was here right now
she'd be eyeing each three of you up
four of you even if you were that way
inclined but like she would fully be
like trying to work out like who's the
best fit for me she'd probably end up
being like they're all lovely marry all
of them yeah they're gonna take chris
chris is six six right now to be fair
and she's
he's like
don't leave out those three inches boy
yeah to be fair my dad my dad is five
foot seven so i feel like i need some of
your six foot nine jeans like in my
family for like for the survivor shoot
your shots shoot your shot emily
is this gonna be a thing
you guys to go on a date you guys
it could be like 11. so you're going to
pay in it
finding love on the pregame
now he's going to ask you to start an
only
fan i've seen some of the options that
my mom has like suggested before yeah
it's pissed
why
it's just like what
it comes from a good place today but
it's just say it with your chest
[Music]
i don't want no disclaimers
you don't take into consideration like
what i might
say with the chest are they found
are they fast
are they fat yes or no just answers
let them are they fat
yes or no listen
what it is it's like
i don't feel like my mom looks at me and
thinks like she doesn't judge for me
just for herself and i feel like the way
that she she looks at like
she's a good person so therefore
that's good for you
but like but you don't think they're
high
you guys
it's just not
they're not taking in your sexual um
kind of thing
who's your who's you guys a celebrity
crush like what's your you know mine
yours i was surprised i forgot her name
but i was like
yeah i mean are you surprised i don't
think i don't think she's that hot i
just megan good yeah you're taking a
question you know in it see my guy knows
my guy knows my guy okay
listen i mean like she's okay okay i
will i want to do a disclaimer she's hot
she's hot in the general population but
this is a celebrity scale which is
different like by celebrity standards
she is like she's like
jordan of like for real yes she is she
is the michael b jordan of women not my
girl type i don't know what to tell you
you guys don't even know
okay what about you guys surprise crush
yeah
i don't know i feel like they're all
nice
okay i haven't really everyone amy
schumer yeah i'm just trying
what can i think you know hold up
[Music]
i don't know how to spell that samira
mighty
and uh paula um
what's this guy's name laurie harvey
oh
she's probably the best right now you
know what she she got ran through and
still bagged michael b jordan
picture
you know what i feel like i feel like
the girls get away with more of the
hotter they are
like guys well like because even laurie
harvey like she's unbelievable
oh yeah i know but she's how does she
she got ran through by everybody
and she's still blogging michael b
jordan that's what i'm saying like
like the hotter a girl is the more a guy
will be like
no i feel like this sounds so bad i feel
like
no
she's like the epitome of being a 10 out
of 10.
i feel like true this is not that like
better megan good huh
i'd say meg if megan good was 9.98 lori
harvey's 9.99
wait you choose megan over laurie really
why 100
really making good she's unbelievable
she's a person i could just be like mom
free
you know
[Music]
oh that's a pretty good thing
yeah what are you saying what is a side
by side comparison uh would you rate
megan good out of ten
okay i've never okay i've seen it in
this picture i'd give her a nine
because i see this one i think
objectively the other girl looks like
more of an instagram body
but i think this girl looks like someone
i would choose over her
that's i think there's something
yeah this huh were you giving her out of
ten
oh she's hot yeah she's hot she's like
i'd give her an eight i'd give the other
girl like
but i'd yeah i mean i give them both an
eight i give them both an eight you give
her an a what do you think is a nine i
think margot i need to know your ten is
like margot robbie is a time
when i'm doing the rating system i'm
only doing face i'm not talking about
their body i'm talking about the whole
thing
my man leading them who is
margot robbie well for wall street
come on you know who she is
she looks like normal
really
she's not correct she's not crazy like
that not like making
this thing here i don't know if i can
say it on here okay say right now are
you sure because it's like it's like
it's like a race isn't it yeah
okay
so
as a white girl that's a six and a black
girl that's a six yeah
it's not the same six
elaborate
you've done it
right this is not for me to ask this is
for like the masses in there whereas
watching maybe they can you know add
their comment in him but
do you feel like a white girl that's a
six and a black girl that's a six is the
same six
and also do you feel that a white girl
that's a 10 is the same as a black girl
that's a 10. what do you mean though
so what what what's the difference to
you
no comment
no you can't start okay so it's i'm
guessing one of which is more your type
so one's better yeah yeah yeah yeah so
it's like you so whichever one is more
your time so like you're gonna write so
are you saying like
so you're saying like because i know
you're being shy
like a black like is it like a black
girl that's a six is better looking than
a white girl that's a six is that what
you're saying are you saying the other
way i'm not no i'm saying like
because this question here sounds like
you know when someone goes oh what's
heavier like a kilogram of feather of a
kilogram of bricks
that's about to get it but like i feel
like there's an obvious answer but it's
not obvious
no what did what what are you saying
what are you saying i think it's what
you i'm i'm out of the loop
unless i got it right the other day what
i asked people to rate me the other day
well one to ten yeah yeah i'm i'm kind
of harsh on people but yeah
what did you say what did you say now i
want to know the gospel
it's all right
i'm an actor i get judged all the time
it's okay
[Music]
um oh i said i give you a sex right yeah
yeah yeah that's right wait wait but
there's more um but i said it depends on
or because okay here's my i didn't say
the other thing no no i
or an a if you're the girl's type
because i like i do the kevin samuels
skill and this is how i rate it like
eight to ten is like you could make
money off of just your face like you
could model five six is pretty cute okay
i'm a solid seven so i i said like if i
had to pick one i'd i'd say six for you
but if you're a girl's type then you
would move up yeah because like i think
you can go up or down a point based on
like if you're someone's height i would
like for example like there's certain
guys that have like a thing for like
tall gingers like it's very it's very
niche right i don't know someone i went
to drama school with no i trained just
like it's a yeah like when they find me
they fall in love because there's just
not many of us but like that's what i'm
saying like in that point like i get a
point because i'm like they're tight
yeah so
um so i think are you saying the same
thing with like white and black exactly
yeah yeah so wait so what was your story
well he repeat that again
that's nice it's basically what i'm
saying is it's okay like why does a suit
yeah
or
black or
um
[Music]
let's let's i was listening to black
white gold that has to say something on
black ops six it's not the same type of
six
but
a white girl that's a ten and a black
girl that's a ten
feels like two different tens
so which one which one's more your type
careful emily's shot shot you know
listen
listen i feel like it's black girls
because he doesn't want to say it
because we're here
he's laughing because it's true
like can i just you can you can say it's
okay yeah
i just got called out at six online
youtube okay don't worry about it it's
okay
because eight oh my god i feel like okay
i've i was
i give myself a five so it's not like
that like i'd give you more than that to
be honest
thank you
i know people just look at me as like
sad
okay i go off all like facial symmetry
so that's what i mean like eight to ten
means your face is so symmetrical on
your face alone you can model like
people you've probably had modeling
agents approach you in your life
six is cute five is like like
average and like so i would say like
five maybe six that's what i would give
myself
and like eight to ten like because i've
never had people ask me to model but my
scale sounds harsher than it really is
because everyone else rates themselves
as a seven but i don't give anyone
sevens because you have to pick you're
either on the more average side around
you're on the model side
i think that's fair the conversation
that i've had is like
are you a a local
team or a worldwide right
celebrity scale yeah
you can say oh oh did this go wherever
um hannah whatever she's a she's a
servant cool like we understand that
she's
reasonably good looking
but
around the world if you take it like out
of what we know taking someone else she
probably wouldn't like three or four
right well there's like it's like
hollywood scale versus like a normal
scale yeah but i think like when i do it
i kind of make it like the hollywood
scale like normal you know what i mean
like there aren't many eights to tens in
general
and and i would i would also i would i
would also say that hollywood is what a
lot of these people don't even look like
how we think they look because instagram
is such a very like and also filters
photoshop i think it's such a real thing
i think that uh
a lot of the time we see these people
completely airbrushed when you see
people in film too like i'd like to
point out as someone who works in film
they have the best lighting on them they
have they do not have yeah
even this is nicer lighting than bright
sunlight if you were to stand out
tonight although yeah i would like to
point out i definitely look like casper
the ghost like i'm i'm i'm very very
well this is like worse than normal
we're getting these lights shout out to
the donations but you're also trying to
balance like different skin tones and
this is another thing in film side note
but like trying to balance if you've got
a scene between someone who's very white
and someone who's much darker skinned
it's diff because you've got to like
them different
but oh hey what was that series that had
um
i swear it was produced um by oprah or
something and it was exclusively black
cast and i've never seen black people
lit so well in it it was a tv series and
it was so good queen something or other
i can't remember what it was now
i can't remember man but it was so good
it was a really really good series too
but if you want it yeah man that was so
well lit anyway um
now what were we saying oh who's doing
ik i think my ten out of ten i was
thinking about well you guys were
talking there's a female model she's
called edward boa
and i think she is the most good-looking
person i've ever seen and she's so
good-looking she's latino
no she's mixed she's mixed her mom is
ginger and her dad is black
actually question how many points does a
good ass add to a girl
like honestly like three points three
points yeah
you said she's a woman uh i think she is
the most attractive girl i think maybe
maybe two
oh i'm so good
what do you what do you guys think a
good ass what does that add to a girl
how many points two
two oh get us to a guy that's a lot it
does a lot yeah at least at least four
that's why margaret robbie is not
allowed
okay here's okay here's a question
here's a question to you guys would you
take
a great body an average face
or a great face for an average body a
great body an average face 100 percent
great
body great body yeah good body same
really and i think that's what i think
you're the other way around which is why
you really rate margaret robbie and we
don't
oh yeah yeah that is because i'm because
when i rate people i'm going off your
facial like symmetry like that's what i
like i think so someone someone thinks
they're like
you do have
like someone's physical
their physicality is gonna play into
you can't just go from their face did
you not see margot robbie's careful
she has a great body yeah yeah
but but
i'm literally i don't i'm not interest i
don't really like i'm not attracted to
margot robbie i'm not into her yeah
do you guys care a question all right
see i keep forgetting your bi so you can
answer this too do you guys care if a
girl's fake at all like she has a great
ass but it's fake great lips but they're
fake and like how much fake is too fake
so like just yes or no yes no
what's the question
do you care for girls like fake at all
like that's fake
not to write her off
don't hit them yes yes no i care
okay yes or no i would never write
someone off
i in general prefer people who come as
they are yeah guy anger yeah
i'll they mess around with but not
seriously that's not how i wouldn't want
to
not fake no yeah i'd have to say
monsters as well so yeah yeah so would
you take a less attractive girl then
that's like more natural yeah to wife up
100 yeah even regardless of wife and up
or no i would rather be with someone who
had these imperfe
whatever as well i would like to say
that a lot of the things that people try
and fix with plastic surgery and
especially when it comes to women's
plastic surgery they are trends like the
fat ass thing there was nothing until
like nicki minaj lips looks so bad i'm
sorry i'm gonna say about it all these
girls look like ducks like with the fake
injection i can't i can't look at it and
again this is another thing of in photos
especially when it's well lit mate you
can make a lot of things look good but
in real life you actually can't like i
would say i would rather have someone
and accept them floors and all and have
someone who especially if it was like
not tastefully done i guess that's
another thing but i think for the most
part like i'd rather have someone who
goes yeah you know what i'm not perfect
mm-hmm love me as i am
i'd rather have that okay
i have a question for you oh yeah
do you think that
so when you like rape people okay
so you know the whole like chad tyrone
yeah
a cha chaz tyrones are they like sixes
and above eight and above what do you
what is it as a
yeah
so do you think someone who's not a chad
or tyrone
who clarified chad and tyrone
tell me eight to ten
eight to ten yeah but then it's hard
it's hard to rate men because like men
it's like women it's more
straightforward like what's your weight
what's your fault like what's your face
that's pretty much it
give or take you know maybe she's a
natural like hourglass or whatever but
men it's harder because
you could have a guy that's a chad but
he's broke
and so where does that make him fall is
he is he a real chat or a fake but like
looks wise i just go off of your height
and your face shoal symmetry so because
someone who's not a chad of tyrone
no i guess he could yeah that's true
okay
um who clarify with a child and tyrones
it's a man of sphere term all right it's
like you probably know you watch fresh
and fit
i don't know what that is though i still
wanna yeah they just always say the
girls will like
the guys who like
the girls the guys that like get to
sleep with girls quickly
so like they'll say like oh she'll f
chat like she makes me go on a date with
her but like she'll f chad right away or
like tyrone like that's the that's the
term they use yeah okay super chat
um
let's
um two pounds sammy cuabia get the likes
up
yeah guys like the video um five dollars
from legend of society i think both
genders choose the right partner in the
end issues women choose right under the
worst circumstances single mom so he
feels used five dollars from guts take
her out on a cheap first date if you
spoil her from the start she won't
respect you and she'll treat you like a
bank
20 from clean leon hell no this goes for
both sides don't get your feelings hurt
because you know who you married five
dollars from
taylor graybill hey check out my mixtape
info 20 super chat a woman should only
expect a man to pay if she's already
communicated that she's a traditional
woman not modern looking for a
traditional man otherwise she should not
offer but actually should pay her meal
does that make it different if what do i
want a traditional man i don't even know
people ask me this question
do you i don't know i always joke about
being a housewife but i work a lot so
i'm like
no but it's not housewives don't work
they just
work in different areas yeah i know
probably not i don't know because they
all they have their own like hobbies and
things their passion they have their own
passions do you know what i mean that
they're free to pursue
yeah i mean like if what i get to pick
to have all my bills paid for and get to
do whatever i want if i had that choice
yeah do i expect that no that's probably
how it put it yeah
like
it's kind of like if you ask a guy would
you marry a victorious secret model that
was like feminine
really if she if she was wifey
okay
you understand the concept though like
whatever ig whatever your ig motor yeah
yeah whatever your
type is
oh my gosh okay guys um i think we're
gonna wrap up the show on that um why
don't you guys go around tell the people
where they can find you and any closing
thoughts that you have
i'm not ready to sign okay yeah uh
you know what it is uh kit
is me on instagram follow my youtube
channel at stay stick with kit where i
talk about dating stuff as well but
probably more on the other side
um
and yeah love love always chatting
thanks for having me thanks for coming
thanks chat
yeah you can find me at emily jane
shepherd that's shepherd spell
s-h-e-p-a-r-d
um
thank you very much for having me i
have said this before to kit but i think
it's really healthy that people who have
different viewpoints actually talk about
them and don't just
argue on twitter or whatever i think
it's i think it's good i think people
can get along a lot more than they ever
think they can i think it's all love and
i think um
just respect other people hear other
people be open-minded
and choose love in your life choose love
and happiness yeah
um this is actually my first
podcast i've ever been on i just wanna
say thank you because it's something
that i wanted to do
so
i had fun doing it and hopefully i'll
get to do more stuff like this in the
future
um my instagram is underscore chris
talia if you want to find me there on
twitter i don't tweet too much and i'm
on there just to look but that's also um
big tower
um twitter
and um yeah this is my first pod cartoon
um you could find that um at sr
oby
and yeah if you're into like fitness or
whatnot then yeah um hit me up okay guys
i think we got one more super chat and
thank you guys all for coming i
appreciate it and you all showed up like
on time which i appreciate that doesn't
happen often
um okay so
five dollars from mgtow by logic wife
duty start on date number one tick tock
ladies do you guys agree with that
really quick you think wife duty start
on first date yes or no
no
no i have to own it
i have to earn it okay
okay guys um thank you so much for
watching as you guys know
if you've watched a couple of these
lives two or more and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef hit
that subscribe button turn on your
notifications because that way you're
gonna be notified every time we're live
and every time we do one of these you
don't want to miss it
um also on top of that don't forget the
meal plan if you guys want to lose
weight i've lost
12 pounds okay maybe 13. i forget
in the past month on this meal plan so
the link to that is in the description